foreign
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
Friday yeah it's Friday and [__] you
guys are uh happy that's Friday probably
getting off of work riding home
I know that there's about 20 in there
that we're just watching waiting for
that damn intro to come in I do that too
sometimes the people that I watch and
[__] oh here it comes there they come
they got the little boys
one of them I listened to is so I can do
just a couple of military guys and
they're just playing music and then you
hear like [__]
radio chatter infantry radio chatter you
know you know everybody reports to
report to your duty stations all kinds
of weird [__] you know and it just
sounds like [__] like you're back in
the Army and then they show up and they
count down for like [__] 15 minutes
so sometimes I'll jump in you know
minute eight and just let it play
you know look at the tablet and [__] I'm
too impatient to do that kind of [__]
yeah no it's kind of like it's like if
you're not on right now I'm gonna go
watch something bye
foreign
remember last week we actually it
doesn't really seem like a week ago but
last week I forgot to play the intro
because I went ahead and streamed yeah
we were just sitting here
and we were saying how lucky it was that
we weren't doing anything embarrassing
yeah you know got all kinds of [__] done
this week repainted my lightning
painted it matte black just good
motorcycle by the way yeah just a rattle
can it was already black I just had to
do some touch up just did some Sprouts
right touch up on
um bought a chainsaw it's already
cutting the tree down up front trimming
it that thing had never been trimmed
it's been there for 16 years yeah it
like hangs over the driveway so every
time I pull into the driveway the top of
the tree goes this house has been here
for 16 years I'm looking at that tree
and it says that tree is older than 16
years that must have been here when this
was a cow pasture yeah I imagine I
probably would so I'm just trying to
trim that huge tree up
and [__] each log
gotta get down there you know cut it in
three foot sections so they're sore
lawn disposal our Branch disposal crew
will be able to pick it up
but what it is I bought uh for the first
time I bought a
electric chainsaw and that [__] works
it's a Cobalt Cobalt electric chainsaw
it's the same one for my electric weed
eater it comes with a big [__]
battery pack and charger
and it's a lot easier than deal with gas
I know you guys remember dealing with
gas and [__] making mixing two-stroke
oil into the gasoline and everything
it's a lot easier than that
um
you know I don't think I would use it
for industrial work but around the house
man that's [__] come in handy
you know it's just the way to go
didn't you plant a peach tree last year
yeah planted a peach tree
bought a peach tree for [__] 60 bucks
down at Lowe's put that on the Lowe's
card
it was the last one dude bought four or
five of them and he was loading them up
on his cart and he's going you want one
of these and I'm like yeah I just want
one because you have the last one
all right thank you because I bought
three last year because they made a lot
of they made a lot of peaches really
yeah so we're gonna be having some
cobbler and stuff like that soon yeah
that's a two-year-old tree
I'm not really sure
um how long they take to it had Peaches
on it when I bought it yeah they're
small though well you said they were a
little yeah they fell off and I was I
put them in there oh well
it didn't matter I had to reloaded in
the car if [__] peaches falling off
of it
the truck if I can put it in through the
back of the back seat and went into the
[__] passenger seat [__] Peach is
falling off
all the [__] dirt coming out of the
bucket going into the truck that's gotta
get it when I get there because I
couldn't stand it up it didn't have a
truck
oh somebody's sending us money thank you
Jeffy art today I drove by the Boca Town
Center mall if you weren't here on
Wednesday we did a show about some
murders that took place there back in
the 2000s yeah uh on my way home I was
considering Living Dangerously by
walking into the Container Store yeah
you're gonna walk in there and like come
out with 300 worth of stuff I need all
of this Tupperware or this like I need
all these containers yeah I'm gonna put
all my things in containers yeah I can't
believe there's a whole entire store
well a whole entire chain of stores that
just sells that kind of stuff
but you know everybody needs containers
I guess
Zach also said
um I saw this up here he was talking
about this the other day and I don't
think I got around to it guys I think I
need help I still have BG songs stuck in
my head and I think I have a crush on
Robin Now kill me
who said this Robin Gibb uh Zach did
yeah Zach Bee Gees is all you bro those
dudes knew how to write lyrics okay
yeah they're good you know you're good
they're dated it's disco sure it's of
the era but there's high quality man
very high quality music I like it more
now than I did yeah well it was
overplayed when we were kids you just
that's what I mean when it's kind of
like divorced from its cultural context
and you're not hearing it all the time
yeah and seeing the fans right that's
true hairy [__]
get these shirts open
the gold chain yeah
they're a little bit they were like your
parents age and the shirts were kind of
like shimmery yeah except fake rayon
satin looking [__] it's pretty cheesy
yeah and they thought they were real
cool yeah well you know run around
spreading STDs
Jenny thinks that shit's fun it is funny
well it's funny because it's probably
what they were doing yeah it's kind of
true syphilis packing [__]
with their disco [__] disco dick
they're [__] drip drip dicks and [__]
[__] all hairy
nah shaving [__]
dingleberries and stuff
underwear wearing [__] and [__]
wow these [__]
right they probably oh they were bad
they also probably smelled like
cigarettes they tell you that [__] was
all natural
yeah it's like in nature man
I would also like to add too that it's
like uh cancer is also natural yeah so
you know just because something's
natural doesn't mean it's good
American Military 100 said the Pope's
Exorcist was [__] awful is it every
demonic possession horror Trope in the
book and not the least bit disturbing or
suspenseful okay like I said that one
was kind of like low down on the totem
pole I really wanted to see
um Renfield
and everybody's not good yeah that
looked really hilarious and also um
everybody's talking about how good the
new uh Evil Dead movie is okay although
I didn't even see the last one that they
did
because I was just kind of like Mal
stick with the original one but you know
if it's really good I'll kind of
I'll give it a shot see your base saying
Camp guy said dig a hundred dollar hole
to plant a forty dollar plant yeah
yeah and Danny Rowland just asked about
is Jenny and time going to the movies to
see Evil Dead rise to review I mean we
might but we'll probably I mean to be
honest knowing us we'll probably just
like wait until it comes out on
streaming and watch it but
that's the thing like we're not
we're not going out tonight so we're not
in any particular Rush we're broke man
which a little bit yeah we're broke I
mean we haven't we have been going out
like pretty much every weekend and so
yeah
probably Jenny's been working herself to
the [__] boat
you work all [__] day and then come
home and then work more yeah yeah I'm
worn out doing stuff because she's got
got other clients yeah because I got I
got a regular job in the two-hour
commute yeah and then I come home and I
have like a bunch of freelance stuff I
have to do yeah I have some freelance
stuff I have to do this weekend too and
she preps for the show that's you yeah
I've tried to do that like that's why I
kind of like in the polls and stuff if
you notice like I've I don't know if
anybody would notice but me but I try to
put
uh topics that aren't quite as
complicated because you know like back
in the old days hi Pokey what you doing
um I would put stuff like you know five
serial killers you probably and now I'm
just like oh my God that makes me tired
just like thinking about it so I try to
keep with more simple things just so the
show isn't super long because you know I
have to go to sleep and like get up the
next more like early the next morning
but also so I have time because really
the poll only closes on Sunday and then
we have to do the haunting show on
Monday so I have to like take notes for
that and all that kind of stuff so I
really only have like a day or two to
like research the Wednesday show I what
I try to do is I try to do like all the
notes on Sunday after the polls close
and then I print them out and then I
take them to work with me and then I'll
read them on my lunch hour and then like
if there's documentaries about the [__]
like about whatever the topic is like
I'll watch those on my lunch hour or
sometimes if there's podcasts about it
like I'll listen to them like in the car
like on the way home so I always so I
feel like I'm not wasting time yeah
because I really do hate that hour long
commute you know what I mean in the
morning it's not too bad because I'm
like barely awake less than two hours of
the day right and it's just like so I'm
so I'm like if I'm listening to
something like research for the show
then I feel like I'm not wasting that
hour just like sitting in the damn car
you know what I mean you gotta keep
looking for something closer yeah I know
because you're probably pissing away 300
a month just in gas well not probably I
am physically yeah 300 yeah I mean you
know it's better than before when I
didn't have any money I mean you know
it's good to have like money coming in
every week but it's still
you know it's still like a lot to get
there
especially because my car is too old
yeah
Zach said I'm actually way more into
their late 60s early 70s non-disco music
it's actually a really pretty and
emotional sounding I've heard some of it
yeah I kind of feel like they are
probably better known for their disco
stuff but
we have I have it like um the guy plays
it at work sometimes
the kill sometimes they'll go off on a
disco
playlist with like BG's and Abba and
stuff like that yeah which is fine with
me that's even Blondie disco was pretty
good yeah I think there was some Blondie
in there too yeah like heart a glass and
stuff yeah there was a couple of songs
that they had it pretty disco yeah
like I said I feel like at the time you
know I was a kid and my dad was more he
liked some disco like he had some disco
records but it wasn't really his main
genre
um you know he was more of like a
Beatles and southern rock kind of dude
but he did like some disco so we had
some of that he had like some Earth Wind
and Fire and stuff too
but I didn't like it at the time because
you know I was just a kid I was you know
like a preteen or whatever and I was
just getting into New Wave so I was kind
of like you know a new wave was like way
cooler than that's cool
mainstream right super super mainstream
I mean uh running right alongside disco
was country western
in California California had a huge
country western scene
red my uncle from Mammoth Mountain was
part of that country western scene of
that era yeah he played oh thank you
thank you very much Victor what do you
say Jenny's new car fun
appreciate it I mean you know knock wood
or knock laptop or whatever I mean that
car that I have yes it's old it's it's a
2004 but she's been
very reliable yeah and I can't I can't
buy a car on and put it on my name until
we get her credit cards wrapped up
that's going to take a while what do you
see we'll see how it goes that way that
way her credit card overheads per month
are not that bad she's gonna help me
with the car
because we're gonna have to go half on
it well yeah because you can use it too
well I only use it to get us some tune
from the club and [__] go shopping
and [__] pretty much yeah yeah because
it's it's not here during the it's not
here during the day during the day you
got the bikes and [__] yeah usually just
like ride your motorcycles
but uh let's see slasher Fred said did
you know that the Army of Darkness March
of the Dead instrumental strong song was
composed by Danny Elfman I did actually
know that yeah he composed a lot in fact
he did a lot of movie stuff well and the
thing about Danny Elfman is that you can
always pretty much immediately tell that
it's him like he has a very distinctive
style we don't want to go Boingo came
out I loved it it was a military school
I've got some Oingo stuff on my Spotify
playlist yeah I had only a lad I had
nothing to fear uh I've got I think I've
got no one lives forever on my uh
playlist and like some other ones
I think I might have only a lad on there
too
I don't know I have like millions of
songs on there I think he had an EP
before that but I didn't have it
Dave is here hello you two hey Dave
what's up we're actually not going to
mannequins tonight we're not going I
came home and I was just kind of like
well because I didn't talk to you today
and I was just kind of like wait are we
going because I have to know because I
have to
and start over with the makeup you need
to sleep no [__] I do yeah if we were to
go out it'd be better tomorrow
yeah and if we go tomorrow I think I'd
rather go to Barbarella because
Barbarella is funner on Saturdays yeah
Saturdays at mannequins is a little uh
douchier than Fridays
and um
it's it's more chilled
yeah
it might be cheaper
because they don't care if you bring
your own alcohol actually
well yeah I mean that's kind of the nice
thing about it so it's in the warehouse
District so people just park out they
just have little campouts in the yeah
parking lot they're out there they bring
their own booze they bring weed they're
just out there and then they'll pop in
and out you know well because Barbarella
only has you know the mix
drink things like in the cans and
whatnot drinks so I don't have the
liquor license right or he does but he
can't use it in that place for some
reason like there's some kind of food or
something yeah it's like it has to have
full service uh amenities or something
about it yeah like he said something
about it but I can't remember exactly
what all the details were it's like some
kind of legal loophole yeah
because he does have I think if you have
a liquor license in in uh Orlando
they're super super expensive like to
get one and they only have so many like
there's like a lottery I don't know if
it's that way still but that's what the
way it was for a really long time priced
amount on purpose because like the
mayors
son got killed by a drunk driver this is
like decades ago and then they raised it
up like a half a million dollars for a
[__] liquor license inside Orlando
and then it became a bunch of gangsters
got involved with uh buying those things
and then renting them out leasing them
out to people
so the same people that banned them also
made a [__] ton of money off of
basically bad in them it's all crooked
it's weird because you know when I was
before I moved out of Daytona
um they were trying to push out the
tattoo parlors yeah too like because
they thought it was like degenerate
people hang on it's like you know this
is before everybody had tattoos yeah and
so they were trying to like keep them
from opening up like within City Limits
and stuff like that I'm like that is the
stupidest [__] ever I'm like this is
like biker Central yeah and I'm like why
are you the people that wanted that to
happen are dead now
those people were like old boobers
Boomers that didn't you know Boomers
that died [__] 10 15 years ago
it's it's hilarious to me how quickly
this [__] changed because I think I've
mentioned before like when I got my
first tattoo I don't even remember what
it was 90s early 90s something like that
um
it was still like not a lot of people
had them you know what I mean other than
you know bikers and [__] like that and a
lot of girls didn't have them yeah
so it was still kind of considered ooh
like you know kind of edgy or whatever
yeah but now it's like everybody has you
see like some Karen mom like in the
[__] grocery store and she's got a
[__] neck tattoo you know what I mean
everybody's got them they got a girl
that follow she plays guitar and does
artwork and basically her whole body is
just blue with a bunch of patterns in it
it's got long dreadlocks or [__]
tongue is split like a fork tug and big
[__] hoops and are stretched out in
her ears and she's gorgeous she's like a
supermodel looking
you know real talented looking it's like
one of the best tattoo jobs I've seen
only her face isn't tattooed
yeah but she looks great here I'll show
it to you she looks great and she looks
I think she designed her own tattoos it
looks like her artwork
to pick something out of damn Avatar she
just looks blue to me with a bunch of
patterns see that's cool though on it
yeah it looks
well well done
I'll show you guys is that funny
but it's just funny how
how much has changed like in that brief
amount of time John Smith said when I
was a kid the only people that had
tattoos were tough guys Sailors and
circus freaks yeah yeah pretty much in
military guys yeah yeah that's why my
[__] sucks so much man we used to do
that [__] in the barracks and stuff only
military guys and convicts [__] had
[__] tattoos man yeah yeah but now
like I said everybody's got him even her
eyes are tattooed yeah see that's that
looks amazing I think
her hair is awesome too yeah
I've always I kind of wanted to dried my
hair like just I don't have to [__] with
I'll show you guys
it should replay that's her
yeah see that's super cool
that's a cool look yeah and it's just
her her whole body's just like uh a blue
pattern blue and gray and
and her um the whites of her eyes are
tattooed blue
um
but as far as tattooed woman
fully tattooed that's the best one I
know of
well like I said it because it looks
like it was a whole aesthetic Choice it
all goes together it's like obviously
like a look you know yeah
because I think a lot of what happens a
lot of times is like sometimes you get a
tattoo and then you get another one and
then you get another one and they don't
really go together yeah so I kind of
feel like which is that sucks because
you know you can't afford to do your
whole [__] body at once because
they're not cheap but you know what I
mean
I would say you know you know what I
always wanted I always wanted
a back tattoo but I wanted
um look at her eyes yeah but I wanted
um
like something to uh to do with like a
mask of the Red Death uh hey girl sorry
and I was actually farting around with
um AI art program the other day that I
use and I put in
mask of the Red Death
Art Nouveau and it came out with this
amazing [__] artwork it came with
like four or five different ones I don't
even know if I could pick but I was like
holy [__] if I could [__] afford that
for a tattoo on my back that would be
super awesome but if you guys want to
see more of this girl she's on Instagram
her name is Jack Nola j-a-k underscore
n-o-l-a
n-o-l-a-m Jack Nola
grampster says uh now high school kids
have tats of skulls with fire coming out
of the eye sockets on their necks yeah
it's just it's not even
people don't even really
look at you funny anymore like I said
back in the old days they did but
[__] there's like that girl that works
at Circle K that we stop she's got like
facial piercings and tattoos and
everything like that and it's like they
when I was growing up they wouldn't let
you like if you got tattoos or facial
piercings you'll never get a job you
know yeah [__] changed so quickly it did
all it takes is I'm glad though all it
takes is for a generation to die out or
get out of power and it just instantly
yeah then they finally shut up yeah stop
telling everybody else what to do
some of the [__] that's changed isn't
I mean
um I think in certain areas [__] just
civilization is just [__] falling
apart uh
but and it you know it's definitely real
you know you look at what's happening in
the west and it does look like something
out of ancient history
instead of the vandals and the [__]
and the [__] Gods attacking it's all
the [__] country people you know or
whatever you know [__] blue versus
red [__] which that was going on in Rome
too everything is just all these old
parallels
but um
I don't know it's just we're in a weird
time
um
some [__] has is not good like you know
I talk a lot to so about to Sophie about
dating you know she's dating all these
different guys and and how different her
generation because she's I think gen Z
right she just turned 30 so no
Millennial I think she's a a a late gen
Z or early how different dating was for
them it was uh not as good as it was for
us we kind of had it made it was all
face to face they're doing it all online
and they're well that doesn't they don't
have any social skills well I mean
that's they [__] each other over really
easily because they just see each other
as data
well the thing about that is like that
that's horses have already left the barn
you're not putting that back in the
bottle you know what I mean that's I
didn't make that claim no what no I'm
just saying that
um you know they grew up like that so
that's just what they're used they're
the whole entire culture is different
than it was when we were younger yeah I
think ours was better they say it was
better too that's why a lot of them are
having Nostalgia for an era they never
lived in
all the 80s stuff that is kind of coming
back
and um well that was like the last
analog yeah generation and it had some
Crossover with early internet too and
then there's a big movement
online the online dating coaches that
were telling everybody to use these apps
are throwing those apps down and still
making videos saying don't use them that
they're that they they feel better
without them the depression went away
they're they're meeting people where
they saw they call it meeting people in
the wild
which is more naturalistic they're just
meeting them in clubs the way we used to
meet them you know
John Smith says I'm Gen X the forgotten
about generation yeah so are we so we uh
yeah I was born in 72. so um yeah people
do kind of forget about us but that's
okay I mean that's that tracks we're
just like many of us yeah I think maybe
it was like slightly smaller and I we
didn't really we get we got shut out of
power because the Baby Boomers stayed in
for so long right it wouldn't give up
any [__] positive or any money
so we never could take their places
right and then but by the time it we by
the time they started to falter
whatever positions they had vanished
they don't exist anymore right so you
can't take over for them
they're going you know what they were
doing so we just kind of got stuck in
the middle
oh well
[Laughter]
that's
that's just kind of like par for the
course I feel like because Gen X was I
could you know it's a cliche to say we
were all just like yeah whatever but
it's like you know there is some truth
to that
uh to that stereotype
uh Victor says the Boomers [__] this
country yeah they did
selfish [__]
well you know they didn't get grandpa
said you actually knew how to know how
to know how to [__] flirt and be nice
back in our days yeah well I don't know
well I don't know about being nice
because I've had people be mean to me
back then too but but you didn't go out
with them though
no no the date you had to flirt and be
nice
yeah you're right granters
Louis says uh tattoos were never a big
deal in my community I remember my
friends getting tattoos in junior high
school in the early 90s holy [__] yeah
um Ben says uh thank you Ben Leviticus
1928. it's talking about the no tattoo
thing that's in the Bible you shall not
make any gashes in your flesh for the
dead or tattoo any marks upon you I am
the Lord just reminded you I'm the Lord
don't do that [__] that's a little
Testament though yeah that's that's
Jewish law that's anything to do with
Christianity
well I don't to me it doesn't have
anything to do with anything because
it's like I'm not doing what the [__]
that's right I'm just saying if he's
doing Bible quotes
to [__] say that it's anti-christian
to get a tattoo it's not anti-christian
Christians had tattoos Romans had
tattoos
and a lot of the early Christians were
Roman slaves they had tattoos
nothing in the Bible about nipple
piercing though
well I don't think it might be something
in there I don't really know
let's see uh Celtic Angel 73 says uh hi
everyone uh Jenny I'm so glad you're
enjoying Bates Motel I knew you would
veriformiga is fabulous in it yes she is
oh she's fabulous in everything I like
her and Freddie Highmore is wonderful
too yeah I just got to I think it was
the end of episode 12. I want to say it
was episode 12. the one with the the one
where the teacher got murdered the one
where the teacher got murdered like the
one after like the the dance or whatever
I'm having a problem tracking it I kind
of lose interest in it as I'm watching
it but people are telling me to stick
with it that in the other season I think
it's really good I'm really it's good
I'm really into it it's good it's just I
don't know just it started to lose me
yeah
crafter says holy cow someone's quoting
scripture on the site right
Danny Rowling asks what's our opinion
about Knight Rider from the 80s the
movie Knight Rider no the TV show
oh the oh with the car kit yeah
I never watched it with I did you know I
watched it a couple of times I think
um I was like oh that's pretty cool a
talking car but I don't think I really
got super into it you know what I mean
yeah I didn't
I'm trying to think of like the stuff I
was watching in the 80s yeah I mean I
kind of liked what did I like in the 80s
I like The Facts of Life and
Knight Rider kind of was for me like on
par up there with like TJ hooker oh yeah
it seemed just kind of like a cheap kind
of generic the chat was in that wasn't
it yeah yeah wasn't Heather Locklear
event I think she was too yeah Heather
Locklear was in that I'm pretty sure
it was just kind of the television
series that were being made in
California at that time they're just I
don't know
kind of like chips
was actually more watchable though than
the the [__] like TJ hooker I mean I
ended up well because we didn't have the
internet back then so it's like when I
was a little kid you kind of just ended
up watching whatever was going on yeah
so it's like sometimes yeah I would
watch chips or Dukes of Hazzard or
something like that Dukes of Hazzard was
almost unwatchable to me
yeah for some reason
I was just I did that was another one
that I would I would quickly lose
interest in it
them Duke boys yeah yeah it's just like
what
it was very light on substance I would
see I would have thought that you would
have really liked that but it would have
been right up your ally no I didn't
really like that one
I like to Battle Star Galactica I kind
of liked battles yeah Galactica too
they're talking don't hassle the Hof
David Hasselhoff ended communism
I still remember that [__] thing
where he was on the Berlin Wall yeah
with that [__] scarf on that [__] was
so funny yeah
evidently in Germany he's [__] huge
I mean I've always heard that I don't
know and it had something to do with
well I think for that generation it had
something to do with him being on the
Berlin Wall yeah and that he got
associated with the fall of the Berlin
wall and [__] you know
the end of [__] East Germany he's a
hero yeah now I kind of Wonder I was I
always want to go to like Germany and
ask them like so are you guys really
super into David Hasselhoff well because
I'm always really interested in like all
these weird perceptions that people have
of other countries because I'm sure that
other I because I watch a couple of
channels of like that are Brits
and um they talk about misconceptions
they had about the United States like
before they came here and stuff like
that and I always find all that kind of
stuff really interesting my
understanding about Hoff is that uh the
Hoff uh is that you know he's a German
American and he could speak German for
from understanding wait could he I think
he could because he didn't know that he
could
I think he was doing stuff in Germany
like making appearances and
being on talk shows and [__] I think he
could speak German
maybe that's why they liked him so much
they're like wow an American that
actually I remember correct if I
remember correctly I think he could I
might be wrong but I remember that I was
doing shows over there
but that was like a long time ago
right I don't think anybody now from
Germany would know probably give a [__]
about David that's what I'm thinking I
think that was like a while back
I think it had more to do with Baywatch
and Pam Anderson and [__] like that
because wasn't he in that yeah he wasn't
very much
I know Pam Anderson was real popular in
Germany Germany has the big tit fetish
they they like that
they like I feel like they kind of do in
the UK they like that yeah yeah Germany
and UK yeah so Pam Anderson ever did
during her time she was
like uh
admired in Germany
like a lot of German girls were getting
that bar that barbed wire wrapped her
tattoo around the [__]
arm that she had remember how she had
that yeah it was around her arm I think
was that real or did she just get that
for the movie I think it was real
I don't really think
I think she actually had that tattoo
Tommy Lee had a [__] ton of tattoos well
yeah I remember that I don't remember
what any of them were I never looked at
him long enough but you know what I mean
just stuff just he just tattooed stuff
just [__] the [__] rock dude
car playing cards and [__] [__] like
that nice guns and
Jokers and [__] yeah
John Smith said as a kid in the 80s The
A Team was the jam yeah I remember
liking The A Team thumb but like I said
you just kind of watched whatever was on
I just feel like we just watched
whatever it was on I never liked 18. we
weren't real Discerning something about
the 18 that actually I couldn't get into
it
something about George Peppard
I remember like an Airwolf a little bit
oh yeah wasn't Ernest borgnite in that I
think I don't know I don't
remember I had that Jan Michael Vincent
I think is what his name was wasn't he
wasn't that [__] in Miami Vice
too it was not the same dude that was in
Miami no I don't think so it was a long
time ago
I barely remember mine
yeah I didn't really watch that either I
remember Don Johnson being in it and I
remember those terrible
white suits and those [__] loafers
with no socks yeah like even back then I
was like man I remember when I was a kid
they were selling Don Johnson Miami Vice
razors and it was a razor that cut razor
stubble
yeah that's right so you could
constantly have stuff so you could have
Don Johnson you could have Don Johnson I
remember that yeah that's really weird I
forgot all about that until you brought
that up right next to the gel yeah right
next to the jail you can get your your
manly five o'clock yeah yeah that you
can wear out to Miami to the club like I
said these are high school boys with
your sockless loafers yeah yeah yeah and
your white linen suit with no shirt
underneath with your Peach jacket
white pants white jeans and [__] with
your loafers and your OG green [__]
sleeveless shirt underneath it
was the icon I had the perception was he
wearing a t-shirt cigarette underneath
the thing or okay sometimes he wasn't
wearing a shirt and I'm like it's so
unprofessional no they usually just wore
like a colored t-shirt it was like a
wife beater under a jacket
yeah that's right yeah and it was a real
light linen Blazer I just remember that
look being you know the thing for a
moment what was Miami man was tropical
and [__] but you had like whoa people
were like [__] it's [__] hot but
you got to be wearing a suit yeah right
so you look like you got money and you
got a [__] sports car so that was
kind of like how that was how you worked
around like having to wear a suit the
coolest thing about that movie is most
people didn't notice it is what was Don
Johnson's Gun was a [__] stainless
Brin tent
and [__] most people didn't know what
that was they didn't make very many of
them
it was an experimental pistol
it was the hottest thing [__] going
it was basically a CZ 75 it carried
about 17 rounds a 10 millimeter which is
like 41 magnum [__] real powerful
we're talking about full boat 10
millimeter that's a 1980s 10 millimeter
when they loaded it hot from the factory
nowadays you get 10 millimeter and it's
like a hot 40 40 Smith and Wesson but
back in the day man [__] the real 10
millimeter was like [__] 41 magnum
well it started blowing up 1911s [__] up
in a 1911 45s were being converted to
that they couldn't survive the
punishment and the brand 10 itself
started to fall apart if you shot it too
much so that was kind of the end of the
brand 10. although it was a good gun it
was well made it was just 10 10
millimeter when it was [__] in it
came out was too hot man
it was a hot [__] round man
blow your [__] up over time
and they made guns back then by hand and
just thinking about it you know I made
them on a drafting table they didn't use
[__] computers simulations and
[__] there wasn't extensive testing
they just went out and shot a few
thousand rounds there yeah it'll hold
Mark says yeah the Hoff was like Elvis
in Germany uh I heard that and grampster
said Germans have weird tastes about
American Stuff Limp Biscuit is huge
there so is Cindy Lopper and Burger King
yeah interesting well Burger King's when
Burger King is good it's not good
anymore I've been to a Good Burger King
in a long time but when Burger King was
good it was good
but it's slipping now I think I got it
from booger cake
everything I get for booger king uh it's
kind of dry dry and the bread always is
kind of stale
well I mean the one that we stop at
sometimes the only time we ever go there
is like on the way to the movies because
it's like really the only thing that's
easy to get to like on the way to the
movies
um it's cheap I'll give it that but you
can get a lot of food for nothing you
can get a lot of food for not that much
though I mean it's edible but I've even
when I was younger I always preferred
McDonald's on Wendy's to yeah to that
Jeff yard said thanks to those Duke boys
and their tight jeans and boots I became
gay LOL
um man maybe Daisy made me straight
[Laughter]
the only chick I've ever seen wearing
cutoffs and nylons though
she's like they're like well you have to
wear these cut off shirts she's like
yeah but my thighs I have like all like
I don't want anybody saying like all the
all the Ripples and
stuff like that so yeah and she had to
put but I kind of feel like that was the
thing though I kind of feel like back in
the 80s people wanted to wear short
shorts they're like well I don't think
my legs look good enough so I'm gonna
put like nude tights on and hope nobody
notices redneck girls [__]
Mississippi and [__] would never put
nylons underneath [__]
they just they wouldn't even thought it
would even if she had bad cellulite she
wouldn't even think about that Ben says
didn't they have fake stubble in a can
yeah they might have although you could
do the same thing for free with like a
cork and a lighter to be honest with you
just
[Laughter]
Ben also says Magnum PI was greater than
all of them
I vaguely remember that I had to
remember that I remember that being all
right yeah that's Tom's up I remember it
was pretty good I remember that being
pretty good well like I said we watched
so much TV back in the day like I don't
even remember a lot of it it was bad
mostly yeah
your standards were lower back then
though yeah there wasn't really a lot to
pick from you just watched what was on
yeah and that was like you know in the
early 80s
to mid 80s like before we really had
well I mean we started having cable
channels like in the early 80s probably
like because I got MTV at 81. and we had
like pay channels like we had HBO and
Cinemax and stuff but that was just
movies but TV shows you know you
basically just had like the networks and
that was about it
I feel like somebody's asking about
Burger King and Hungry Jacks what do you
say about an Australia are Burger King's
like Hungry Jacks have become in
Australia they want you to order stuff
through a computer terminal then half of
it isn't available I don't know about
that like the Burger King that we go to
you still order at the
at the counter like regular
but I have been to some McDonald's where
you order at a kiosk you don't have to
yeah but a lot we'll do something like
that now a lot of them are like that now
well to be honest like a lot of people
just order through the app and then just
pick it up which you know you just go
through the you order through the app
and then you go through the
drive-through and pick it up so it's
like much easier but I don't know I
never run into that problem in Burger
King because they still out of they
don't have kiosks in that one because
the the Burger King we go to is like not
one of the higher end ones they really
need to fix it nothing to tear that one
down it's not in a good location and
they don't they can't get any [__]
labor anybody to actually work in there
everybody's in there just [__] yeah
we went in one time and like we thought
there was like nobody there there was
like nobody in there and I was like so
should I crawl over the counter and like
make my own food or yeah your kids in
the back and then finally somebody
wanders it from the back it was like one
person yeah that was like one person
there yeah so I was like I mean that
one's not it's a terrible location you
wouldn't think it was a terrible
location because there's a bunch of
other stuff there like there's a really
popular restaurant there there's like a
popular Pizzeria there's a Starbucks
right there yeah but it's not a good
place for for that though yeah it's not
a good place for that and it's kind of
awkward to get into like the parking lot
is kind of awkward you know it's Hungry
Jacks it must be Jack in the Box here
or may or it might just be its own chain
yeah you know what I mean like they
could in Brazil they had Jack in the Box
but they couldn't call Jack in the Box
because box box in in Portuguese refers
to a shower Jack in the shower and
they're just like that nobody's eating
burgers in the shower yeah they don't
know well I mean I'm not yeah they don't
know they don't know what a [__]
jacket Jack's in the shower
the burgers are really clean or they're
damp or what you gotta go in the shower
and eat that [__]
now I just had like a visual of some
some dumpy guy like in a shower like
eating a drippy Burger King Burger they
just called a jack
I'd have caught a [__] jack [__]
would it be jack [__]
well that's the thing though I mean
I don't know if he had that name I guess
you couldn't complain all the jack [__]
just kind of means like nothing yeah
nothing like I got an oven you got jack
[__]
yeah Ben says Hungry Jack's is Burger
King in Australia because the name was
already taken when they expanded here
they have Whoppers and stuff okay okay
see that is very interesting to me the
whole Burger King was already taken the
way yeah yeah yeah one thing I remember
from being in the UK was and I don't
know if it's still prevalent nowadays
but they had a lot of they have all of
the same chains that we have too pretty
much but um they had wimpy
that was which was kind of like Burger
King or McDonald's or something like
that they had a ton of those
I know uh
I was watching this Russian uh guy who
uh he has his own YouTube channel
with all this Ukraine thing kicked off
McDonald's pulled out of Russia
all right so they lost all their
McDonald's
but instantly
um a bunch of Russian companies
[__] chipped in
to make fake McDonald's in Russia I
don't remember it's it's I don't
remember what the name is sick Donald's
no
McDonald's well I know I'm making a joke
it has a different name
but uh dude went in there to review it
he got a bunch of stuff he said it's
exactly
like uh the original McDonald's it's the
same suppliers and everything just that
none of the motifs can be the same
nothing can be everything has to have a
different name
you know what I mean
like you can't call anything a Big Mac
or anything you know
but I said it's exactly the same they
did it without any uh
with any McDonald's involvement so
there's a Russian
McDonald's clone
all over [__] McDonald's all over
Russia now which is stupid they should
have just stayed there making money
Ben said the actual McDonald's
restaurants are still there in Russia
but the parent company pulled out
is that what it is okay well he went and
got uh he went and reviewed
the one that got converted to the to the
Russian equivalent of the McDonald's he
couldn't tell apart
it was good
Zach said me and a dude uh went on a
date yesterday and we went to Wendy's we
were literally the only two people in
there besides the employees I was always
honestly
um as far as Burger not so much because
I haven't eaten one a long time but I
always liked Wendy's more like out of
the big three like the best out of all
of them I think because they had
frosties for one and two because they
had baked potatoes
and neither Burger King nor McDonald's I
forgot about it I will add have baked
potatoes yeah baked stuffed baked
potatoes all the [__] on it yeah yeah
also Wendy's has that chili which is
yeah I'm not a huge chili fan but you
know it's good I haven't been to a
Wendy's in forever I need to go I
haven't been in 20 years
yeah what was the last time we went to
what well we've been to one together but
it was a long time ago
like I don't even remember how long ago
it was it was probably like eight or
nine years ago probably and I used to
take as this is a
what I kind of miss it
when I was in the Army we'd buy all
kinds of [__] from like the local PX and
stuff and stash it in the barracks
you could have canned food you just
couldn't have any you could even have
refrigerated food but yeah they changed
that anyway the uh I used to do I used
to get a cad chili with the beef cheap
[__] like you would put on top of a
chili dog you know
and pour it I would pour that over a
pack of Fritos get a package yeah a lot
of people do that it was good man for a
pack of Fritos in a bowl that's not that
whole thing of chili in there and I
think I put some like uh tabasco hot
sauce on it and uh like a couple slices
of [__] Velveeta cheese on it and pop
it in the microwave
and when you were drunk and the barracks
man [__] when you're in your 20s
that's a great Peak drunk view yeah
you're like oh man
your friends trying to steal it where's
mine where's mine all that kind of [__]
you know
yeah John Smith says the great chain in
the UK is Greg's oh I agree a bakery
that sells sausage rolls and they are
everywhere man I used to go in there in
the one in Cardiff and I used to get
those pork and apple pasties oh my God
those were so good yeah they had some
good they had some good stuff Victor
Victor called it [__] Frito pie this
is popular here I think he's in
California
yeah I've heard of that like a lot of
people Frito pie that's what they call
it all right yeah
yeah I was gonna say that's not that
unusual I hear a lot I just haven't had
it that [__] was white trash as [__] I
haven't had it in a long time but
thinking about it maybe want one
because I just remembered being good
well some of us some about those Fritos
getting hot and moist inside that beach
moist yeah because it gets kind of soft
you get kind of soft a little bit yeah
they're good
Zach says these days Taco Bell is Peak
drunk food for people my age yeah I was
just reading an article about
um he's in Texas okay that's popular in
Texas all right yeah I was gonna say
I've I've heard of that like a lot of
people have that it's not like I said
I'm not a big fan of Fritos or chili all
that much so it's like I never really
wanted to eat anything like that but
yeah Zach said I think my favorite fast
food item now is the Breakfast
Crunchwrap at Taco Bell every time I eat
one I feel like I'm gonna have a heart
attack for a few hours after but it's
worth it I don't eat a lot at Taco Bell
we don't have one around here I mean
there's one around here I'm sure but I
don't know I never see where it is yeah
that's the thing it's like where we live
if you go like five six seven miles up
the road
um you know yeah there's a bunch of fast
food [__] up there but it's like not
around here so much there's really not
any fast food around here down there's a
there's a Subway in the Circle K
and then there's uh
uh where's the closest other fast food
place I don't know like I said we have
like a breakfast like a breakfast brunch
place we have a Chinese restaurant we
have a Domino's I guess that's kind of
fast food when I was in California we
had Taco Bell back in the 70s and 80s
Taco Bell we had another one called Del
Taco
and Del Taco was like that was like
welfare Taco Bell we got it though yeah
we got a doll tacos there's two in
Orlando but she took me to this one over
here
uh she took me to the uh I guess it's
the same company it's called Delta yeah
it was good it was a lot better than
than they have tacos and french fries
yeah it was real good you could even get
tacos with french fries on them which
not really that but I mean well you know
probably all right so it's not real
offense we're crazy but neither is Taco
Bell so yeah if it's good I'm gonna eat
it I don't care
I don't know I thought a gorgita was
just something Taco Bell made up no they
have those in Mexico yeah yeah
apparently but like I said I was just
reading an article about Taco Bell and
about how they're like yeah they they
know they have this reputation as being
like Oh the food that Stoners eat you
know what I mean and that they always
come up with all these crazy concoctions
like you know the Dorito taco what the
[__] is that thing called that has the
the thing made out of Doritos or
whatever which was like a genius idea
because they sold like a billion of
those but they're like yeah so they
think it's like a bunch of Stoners Like
sitting around trying to make up new
iterations of stuff but they said no
they're like super calculated about they
have like this huge R D team yeah that
like puts together everything and they
they run it through
um like to see like how fast people can
make them like you know so they can do
them in the restaurants like and they'll
get them out quickly and stuff like that
but they're really really calculating
about all the stuff they come up with uh
Ben says I hear Waffle House can be an
entertaining place to visit you're gonna
get in a fight at Waffle House probably
well I mean we stopped going because
[__] it was gonna almost got to fight
while fast we used to we're where where
Tom used to live yeah
um before we moved in together like we
would stop at Waffle House because right
on the way home you know what I mean and
Waffle House it's drunk food you want
like some eggs and some waffles and or
some biscuits with jelly and hot sauce
on them if you're Tom
and uh
it's it's fun but there's all the other
drunk people in there too and if you're
all kind of gossed out there's kind of
like some rednecky yeah Vibe going on
there so and sometimes people are okay
with it and sometimes not so much so you
kind of gotta watch your step
is to what I'm saying it was a redneck
so it was Hispanic guys well I mean that
why not yeah I don't even remember they
just want to talk about the Matrix and
[__] and I was like God
well and we were talking about that just
the other night because I said remember
how we were talking about when Netflix
when they did the Wednesday show and I
was like oh here comes the new the new
rotation of like all the god stuff where
everybody's thinking that you're
Wednesday but um because you have to
understand that like people that have
been in the gaussian I was like this
goes in Cycles like everything you know
I was like the first time I remember it
happening was when Tim Burton first got
big like when Beetlejuice came out yeah
um then like if you were cast out
everybody's like Beetlejuice Beetlejuice
and then it was Marilyn Manson and then
it was The Matrix yeah and then it was
like everyone thought you were copying
that or the crow that was in there too
so like ever so every couple of years
like some gothy media will go mainstream
and then everything in the mainstream
people everybody thinks that you're
ripping that up yeah I think that you're
just because
it's like dealing with religious people
[Music]
they have no idea what they're talking
about I want to be an expert
Yeah well yeah and it's the thing it's
like this shit's been going on for like
decades and you just only now like found
out about it and then suddenly you're
kind of like Mr oh you're into this
without the other thing and I'm just
like you just have no idea what you're
talking about please leave me alone but
you know what I mean it's
but I kind of worried that that would
happen like when when Wednesday came out
but
it hasn't been
too bad so far I haven't really got any
any crap about that but maybe because I
don't
I don't know why but you know uh
granther said Waffle House grits taste
like warm boogers yeah they don't season
them
unfortunately their waffles are pretty
good and um you know the eggs and
biscuits and stuff I mean it's hard to
mess that up really
even like kind of shitty eggs and
biscuits and Waffles are still pretty
good you know what I mean kind of like
pizza
it's you know it's there's good pizza
and great pizza and stuff but pizza is
good like pretty much
no matter how crap it is Victor said
real gorditas are nothing like Taco
Bells they just call them gorditas yeah
I was watching um yeah we
got real ones here man
he's got my Mexican restaurant right up
here you know registry they have
gorgeous yeah they're not like a
they're not like a Taco Bell gordita but
a [__] a Big Mac is nothing like a
home hamburger that's nothing like a
hammer you know what I mean it's just
and I feel like Taco Bell have kind of
pivoted away from because when they
first started out I was just watching a
video last night or the night before on
weird history food about Taco Bell like
the history of Taco Bell and actually it
was on that uh food that built America
or whatever like that History Channel
[__] they did an episode about Taco Bell
too and they were talking about when
they first started out obviously like
Mexican food wasn't mainstream like in
you know most of America yeah so they
kind of started out more as like a
Mexican food even though even from the
beginning it wasn't super awesome the
dude that made it really didn't know
much about food no all right he just he
wanted it he wanted a fast food that
could compete with a hamburger
he was in California
he saw migrant workers and do induced
from Mexico working on construction
zones eating some he had never seen
before was a [__] taco
and he goes man that that's basically a
hamburger you got a kind of bread with
meat and vegetables because that's a
[__] hamburger it's just a different
shape
the heat never tasted it you know
so he got his hands on one and tasted it
he goes yeah that's pretty good
I can do without that seasoning though
because this was the 50s right
Americans of the 50s [__] they grew
up in their eating the food that their
parents gave them from the depression
they didn't have spices I mean yeah you
put black pepper on something that would
freaked the [__] out that's some fancy
[__] wow it's hot I got a dunk a nice
catalog from the 30s downstairs that's
been in the family forever that has to
explain to you what oregano is right
because they're going to teach you how
to make tomato sauce the spaghetti sauce
and if you execute that
that tomato that that spaghetti sauce
recipe out of that Duncan Hines 1935
cookbook you will throw that [__] away
that is because I've made it many times
when I was a kid
they didn't have any ingredients
it's sour
it's just did they not put any sugar in
it it had a little bit but they didn't
not enough not enough they didn't
understand the whole acid no sweet
balance no type of situation no that
that [__] wasn't wasn't that [__] wasn't
rocking yet it was salt and pepper
with uh water
uh tomato paste
a little bit of sugar
a little bit of garlic and oregano
that's it
and I think it had garlic I think it did
man it may not happen it must have
tasted like like low rent
franco-american spaghetti worse worse
worse like super thin yeah thin thin and
kind of tart
and salty I don't like that and um you
wouldn't you wouldn't like it you
wouldn't like it I don't even I may have
not had or made it may have not had
garlic in it it just tastes super
incomplete
but that's what this I guess they didn't
know any different it has to tell you
about Italian food and it's called
foreign food
yeah that's funny and that's something
that I actually remember I mean it was
going away when I was a kid like in the
70s but it was still kind of considered
not so much Italian food but I kind of
feel like Chinese food was for real like
still considered I think there's Chinese
food in that there in that 1930s uh
Duncan Hines recipe everybody thought
Chinese food was La Choy man you did it
in that book fig big [__] can I think
they still sell that I remember I need
to go in there and get it I think it's
just it just uh stir-fried rice
it has that
and um I think it has orange duck
and um that may be it
you know what I mean it was just
[__] from the 30s
and things like chow mein
yeah diced up vegetables on I think
there might be an egg foo young
recipe
they had that that should go American
Chinese food goes way back
I like egg foo young
a lot
I get into that we used to go to this
place called
what was the name of that restaurant
that we was used to Lee's Palace Lee's
Palace that's right yeah yeah yeah they
had really good eggplant in there
that was like it was mostly pickup but
it had like a big nice like sit-down
area too so a lot of times we went in
there and sat down and ate but we were
the only ones doing that because it was
just picking stuff up
crafter says is there a tougher job than
being a Waffle House waitress on the
night shift I always felt sorry for them
what they had to deal with yeah that
must be a real [__] show
um you know anywhere that you have to
work in Food Service where everyone is
drunk
and they're all like coming in I don't
really Envy that must be the [__]
worst Waffle House Is Not is not Peak
drug food though Peak drug food is
[__] White Castle and if you don't
have White Castle it's gonna be a
crystal yeah which are pretty the same
thing
I don't know how I did some of that [__]
that I did at a White Castles when I was
[__] younger
I would go into White Castle just
blasted
and think I think I'm pretty sure that I
ate
more than a dozen hamburgers
it might have been two dozen I remember
because you can't believe it because you
could get a big box yeah like a family
[__] box
you're just like I'm my own family yeah
just sit there you're not going there
drunk you know what I mean and go
and my eyes are getting bigger than my
stomach you know what I mean and I'm
[__] going yeah you know you got the
[__] you got the family box
I'm gonna need that yeah
I'm gonna be a whole fan
you can be as big as the whole family I
remember that [__] was like [__]
almost the size of a briefcase
yeah I think Crystal had something
similar yeah like that it's like that
you know you unfold it and all the
[__] stuff go to the office
I can't remember how many were in there
but I'm pretty sure I ate all of them
I wouldn't doubt it pretty sure I don't
know how I did that kind of [__] back
you know well you know when you're
younger you could just do for a
metabolism well yeah you had super
metabolism I've never had super
metabolism but you know what I mean you
probably did
but you still have that because a lot of
times like we're coming back from the
club and we go to Circle K and I get my
little I get like a little can of
Pringles and a little chicken salad
sandwich or cranberries on it and then
he'll go in there I always say I'm gonna
get something different but I'm just
like man that I really like that chicken
salad sandwich but um he'll go in there
and he'll be like well if they have the
XXL burritos I'm gonna get two of those
and this other thing and then he can
only eat one he's like I can't eat these
I was like yeah he eats them both up and
he's like I can't eat this
and then I usually eat about half the
little because it is a little can of
Pringles I usually about half of that
when I was younger I could have eaten
all that [__] I could have eaten it I
don't know if can any of you people uh
remember how many was in that big box of
[__] White Castle White Castle it was
either a dozen or two you could probably
Google it and I think it it in in those
days you could get it for like 10 bucks
you know it was it was Jeff yard said he
thought it was 50 Burgers to a box
50 to a box I don't [__] know
I just remembered that it was about 10
bucks it was about the price of a pizza
per se
and it was just an ungodly [__]
amount of [__] hamburgers
for those of you people in other
countries that don't know anything about
White Castle White Castle is actually
the original hamburger
that's where the hamburger came from a
lot of people can't accept that
hamburgers were invented by White Castle
and they sucked they [__] up
but they're freaking kind of sucks when
it first started out there was something
good about them it was just a dinner
roll I mean it's like a slider
essentially what they would call a
slider nowadays yeah nowadays you caught
a slider but that was the original
hamburger Square about that big
and they had it a meat Patty that was
the same size and shape as a cracker a
Saltine cracker had holes in it and
everything
and they would cook those meat patties
along with the onions and it would all
be dripping the grease would all be
dripping and they and they would put
those in steamed
dinner roll yeah dinner rolls
and the basic serving came with like
four of them
and that was your service
and then you know you could have fries
on the side and just came to ketchup
it had pickle on it too each one had one
pickle I feel like didn't they I mean
Crystal all it had on all it came on it
like out the box was the fried onions
mustard yeah and one pickle slice yeah
it might have had a little bit of
ketchup on it well I no because I
because I like ketchup and I always had
to add it okay all right because they
didn't add it it just came with mustard
I'm pretty sure it came with mustard on
it and onions and one little slice of
pickle because the meat is there's not
there's not much substance to the meat
it's pretty thin
it has a meat flavor okay A little bit
of texture and the the dinner roller the
bun is so soft and Airy
because it's kind of like steamed
you can eat a lot of them yeah
because if you were to ball it up in
your hand it would probably be
just like a bite yeah
it would probably be like a little the
size of a Super Bowl or you know even
smaller
if you were to knock all the air out of
it
Jeffy I remember you being able to eat
like a dozen of them at least he Googled
it and he said in a box was 18 of them
18. okay that sounds about right I'll
eat the [__] out of 18 of them you could
probably still do that I could probably
do that I've seen how much you put on it
might have been two dozen at the koiwan
buffet 18. so 18 White Castles would be
no sweat yeah I feel like and it cost at
the time it cost about what a what a
what a uh what like a a medium or a
large single top of pizza would cost
like from Domino's for the whole box
yeah yeah it's about 10 bucks because
grandpar said that they they used to be
25 cents each yeah they used to be cheap
now they're a little more expensive yeah
I remember well like I said we didn't
have White Castle here we had Crystal
which is kind of the same thing
White Castle had good french fries they
were ruffled
remember them they were good we didn't
have White Castle I told you no the same
as Crystal well I don't know if we ever
got fries from Crystal though oh okay
now that I think of it because usually
my Grandpa would go and like just get a
big bag of them I think White Castle's
and crisp Crystal are the same company
yeah they must be I mean they just maybe
it's just like a different region
because I feel like crystal is more um
Southern like Southeast yeah
John Smith says in one of the letters of
H.P Lovecraft he describes having a walk
on the wild side and goes to an Italian
restaurant has this exotic dish ravioli
oh yeah yeah
I'm proud of HP because that's like
something that he wouldn't or he'd be
like oh my god oh he's like [__] yeah
those are not eggloos
it doesn't know
oh no poor HP he had some issues yeah
you guys are foreigners that that must
have been he pretty much thought
everybody was foreigners except him
except him yeah
you know exotic foreigners that are
dangerous they're coming after you
they're gonna destroy the civilization
yeah read his story um what's it called
horror Red Hook or Terror at Red Hook or
something like that
yeah I mean a lot of his stuff is like
super racist but I kind of feel like
that that one to me like came across as
the most races
because it's like really clear like what
he's talking about you know what I mean
he doesn't even bother like disguising
it a little bit without that he wouldn't
he would not without his xenophobia
you would not get that kind of horror
that he's writing that's what I mean so
it's kind of like a change off it's kind
of like yeah it's uncomfortable to read
nowadays but if he hadn't been so
[__] weird and so scared of
everything he might not have come up
with the [__] that he came up with he
was paranoid yeah and like I said he had
some issues he got better when he got
older though he did yeah he did get a
little bit better and his uh his
girlfriend was Jewish
she was the one that actually backed him
and [__] helped him yeah yeah so he
wasn't she made him go to like New York
City which I imagine he was like having
an anxiety attack yeah that [__] never
got out of the house
yeah he just like lived with his mom and
his aunties or something he didn't know
what he was talking about Jeff yard said
I couldn't imagine what HP Lovecraft
would think of pad thai
[__]
you know he'd have to get up and he'd
have to get up and leave oh I can't I
just
bringing my fainting couch well it's
just funny now because
like I said just in our lifetime I
remember you know Chinese food was like
the big can of La Choy you know from the
grocery store safe way is that right or
you know or the Little Dixie you know or
if you had tacos you had the little what
the [__] is that brand that comes in the
box like Ortega Ortega or whatever we're
taking shells yeah like you would just
get that and like put shredded up
lettuce on them which Mexicans don't do
that that was just a big old bit Dorito
pretty much and that and and it's just
funny how in our lifetimes it's changed
so much and now everybody just eats
everything you know what I mean and
nobody thinks anything is weird anymore
well it wasn't us
it was the Boomers yeah and even even
my parents age they had some food
paranoia that things that were like my
mother still convinced that Japanese
food is dangerous that it'll kill you
because it's it's raw
and eating raw fish is extremely
dangerous all kinds of [__] I don't see
too many dead Japanese uh dying of that
yeah I mean just
other than maybe Fugu yeah but nobody's
eating that shit's expensive right
the Boomers didn't know what they were
talking about they just believed any old
[__] paranormal paranormal any any
kind of paranoid hype they'd believe any
paranoid hype yeah if you get a piercing
in your nose your nose will fall out if
you get piercing in your tongue your
toggle fall out it's all kinds of weird
[__]
and I always what it's like they
obviously didn't know Jack about Jack
but they were just kind of like I don't
know if they were just repeating stuff
they heard or it was like they didn't
like it or were scared of it so they
just made up some story about it I don't
[__] know but
it's just just very very silly very very
silly I just remember and I remember
there was a lot of stereotypes like
around quote unquote
foreign food like when I was growing up
you know stuff about Chinese food oh
it's like you know there's never cats
around the Chinese restaurant you know
like all that kind of crap and I'm just
like okay whatever but
I'm just I'm glad all that shit's gone
that's like [__] I mean as you know
I'm sure some people still think that
stupid crap but back then it was very
very prevalent
um John Smith said he also talks at
Great length of his fear of seafood
yeah it doesn't surprise me as afraid of
seafood because a lot of his uh a lot of
his monsters were
I was talking like this I had a boomer
jump on me in the damn comment section
that I was aged
[__] it's not all Boomers it's just in
general yeah not all Boomers well and I
try and I say
like you guys that have hung around here
a long time no when I just when I [__]
on old people or somebody look you could
be 20 years old and be an old person
okay it doesn't have to do with like how
chronologically old you are it has to do
with how like psychologically old you
are do you know what I mean so
I'm not shitty because I've known really
really cool 75 year old people and I've
known really really lame 20 year old
people so it doesn't have anything to do
with how old you are chronologically
Zach says would you eat this the Indiana
State dish the pork tenderloin sandwich
actually
um Tom makes that like I don't know if
it's exactly the same but we make pork
tenderloin a lot and we put it on a
sandwich sometimes
and the state dessert is the vanilla
sugar cream pie
um I don't think I've ever had that but
that is totally something I could get
behind because all of those things sound
delicious and I'm sure that they're all
delicious together
um I wonder what the
I'm sure the Florida dessert is probably
key lime pie
but I don't know what our national dish
is yeah I know oranges and all that kind
of crap but do we even have a state dish
I don't know
now that I'm thinking about it
like I said I'm sure our state dessert
is Key Lime Pie because that's like a
big Florida thing
but
I can't think of a Florida dish that's
specifically Floridian
other than maybe some seafood or
a Cuban sandwich I don't really know but
that's not all of Florida that's just
like South Florida and like the West
Coast a little bit where there's like a
big Cuban population
oh Zach said I think yours is the Cuban
sandwich okay fair enough that was it
was literally that was the only thing I
could think of and like I said the Cuban
sandwich it's widespread but it's kind
of more
that's it's more a South Florida thing
like the Cuban sandwich oh yeah or Tampa
if you go to Tampa that you can get a
Cuban sandwich anywhere like they got
them everywhere and they're really
really good actually here you can get
they have them in like Publix and [__]
you can get Cuban sandwich here
just a sandwich to me pork sandwich it's
pork and it's got It's what else is on
there some of those kind of bread and
it's got yeah it's like Cuban bread yeah
I like pork steak I like chicken
sandwiches but he well he was talking
about the Indiana State dishes the pork
tenderloin sandwich and I said well you
make those sometimes yeah but I don't
know if it's exactly the same as the
Indiana State one and I said our state
dessert is probably key lime pie I
imagine
because that's Florida's kind of known
for it they got some Cuban restaurants
here
where they're just more like eateries
you go in there and for six bucks as you
can just eat your fill with a bunch of
beans and rice and pork and
Cuban stuff and
you wanna you won't have a choice it's
just gonna be kind of like a uh here's
your rice here's your meat here it is
you know almost kind of like a um
remember they had that heading towards
Sanford
I ate there once it was a long time ago
though over over 10 years
when you went over the bridge yeah
went over the bridge and uh before you
got to the cobblestones
yeah something there
or no they're at that intersection there
was a there was a Cuban
restaurant on the left and it was kind
of like a
is this the place where Cubans went to
eat
they had lunch and dinner that was it
yeah and it was just the same meal for
everybody
there was no menu
no like here you'll do it you'll like it
yeah
but the thing is there's only like six
bucks for a huge [__] plate well that
makes things really yeah because well
you because there's no choice
so therefore you can buy bulk [__] and
there's no waste and you can still make
profit yeah I mean if you just make one
thing and it's really really good and
everybody comes together yeah
specifically then yeah it seems like a
decent business model it's just
traditional Central and South American
food you know beans and rice and pork
with sides like might be I don't know
might be fried plantain or something
it's probably different every time
Zach says uh and we gave the country
Steak and Shake Indiana
um and he says I don't know how big of a
brand Steak and Shake is outside Indy
but oh my God it's so good we actually
have yeah we have a bunch of Steak and
Shakes here in Florida
um I used to eat at the one in Daytona
and we've eaten out the one there's one
by the Altamonte Mall where the movie
theater we used to go to it's always
jam-packed yeah it's always like really
crowded their milkshakes are amazing I
like their fries too they have like
those shoestring fries and their burgers
are always it's good super sloppy to eat
sandwiches are greasy but good oh yeah
yeah it's like the good kind of Grease
yeah but yeah we used to go through the
drive-through there sometimes I mean it
takes a while because they cook
everything from scratch but you know
but um
yeah he was talking about John Smith was
talking about HP lovecraft's fear of
seafood yeah
I know that some people don't like sibo
like my sister is kind of like that like
she likes tuna but she will not eat like
any other kind of seafood and grosses
are out but I'm like the opposite I'll
eat pretty much anything comes out of
the ocean only thing he came from a time
when they didn't knew they didn't know
what the surface of the Earth was like
much less what was underneath the ocean
you know
he came from a time when they thought
that you might be able to find an island
somewhere that had dinosaurs or King
Kong on it
yeah what do you mean that didn't happen
it might be a possibility you might find
Skull Island
it's out there before satellites and all
that [__]
I mean I I agree with him that
underneath the ocean is scary like that
did you pull out a big old [__]
Lobster and [__] Claws and armored
scales on it and then you pull out a
[__] octopus you know then you see
something the size of a blue whale
you're gonna be like nah [__] this
there's no telling what's under there
there's no Talent well that's true
though what if there's a [__] Lobster
the size of a blue whale down there what
if there's a wow you know yeah
get the drawn butter yeah there's a lot
of weird things about
some of those old drawings
of giant
octopus [__] tearing ships apart and
giant squids tearing ships apart there
may be something to that
um
those drawings all come from like the 15
1600s
some of it's 1700s but mostly 15 1600s
and that was before commercial whaling
started
it may have been when whales were more
common more plentiful there was more
meat out there swimming around and
something like a squid maybe or an
octopus maybe could get to that size
and if it got big enough to attack
whales and [__] and maybe and eat whales
on a regular basis
how well can they get big enough to
attack a ship
because a Humboldt squid will [__]
throw a tentacle out and grab a guy on
the back of a fishing boat and pull him
in the water and kill him and eat him
and I will note that you know that that
app that Humboldt squid and you know
those big giant squid are pretty [__]
big even nowadays you know even with the
commercial fishing and stuff yeah so
imagine how much bigger they were back
in the old days yeah so they're showing
like a Spanish a drawing of a Spanish
Galleon and half of it's just covered up
by a [__] squid and it's it's
tentacles are going into the windows and
Squid Specialists and octopi Specialists
are going yeah that's something that's
an octopus would do
grab onto the side of it if it was big
enough grab up on on the side of a ship
and start sending tentacles in there to
see if there's food in there they're
smart yeah like it's a box of snacks so
I'm just gonna like feel it and it may
not be trying to split the ship in half
you know Sailors of the time might have
thought that but probably what it was
doing is trying to grab the cargo and
grab men and get some food and then jump
back off into the water
that sounds plausible to me
yeah I mean if it was big enough like
you said you know they got to find some
food too I'm just trying to get food
just a little floating box of snacks
like going by like you know he's gonna
check that yeah let's go get some of
these dudes off this ship and we'll eat
them
and hey what's this is this a barrel
what's in this oh it's got Pork yeah
because then it has salted pork right
Barrel oh we're gonna take this
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
save this for later
[Laughter]
Megalodon sharks and giant sharks
they found teeth on the bottom of the
oceans the size of a man's hand you know
[__] huge shark oh my God I would
[__] a break of myself
well we don't know how long a shark
lives
they found shark that are giant
we gotta at least be 100 years old and
they're just as healthy and just as
vivacious at a hundred
as they are when they're 10.
how long can a shark live
if it has enough food can it live
hundreds of years and grow really big
because back in the age of the dinosaur
and everything there was just a lot more
meat out there to eat
so maybe the Megalodon was big by
today's standards but maybe if you were
to just let go a modern shark of today
from today like with a time machine just
take it in the pack and let it go maybe
300 years later it's as big as a
Megalodon 300 years later you know maybe
it might live to be 300 years you don't
know
imagine like [__] sharks is getting
bigger and bigger bigger than 300 years
just farting around in there yeah I'm
gonna eat that [__] I'm gonna eat that
[__] too I'm gonna eat then they just
threw for 300 years doing it yeah well
they've had turtles that what can live
near 200. yeah it was like Galapagos
tortoises and stuff they live a long
time yeah they get a little bit they
don't eat meat though isn't that
interesting yeah and they get kind of
slower
well they start out pretty soon
they're very chill
now I've heard they have no idea that
they don't really know how long an
alligator will live no alligator has
ever been observed dying of old age
and that um they had I think the oldest
one they knew of was an alligator that
was like 125 years old
and it was huge
and it died because the Dude taking care
of it died and and he stopped and it
stopped feeding it and it you know it
starved
because they didn't know that he was
dead but he had it out in [__]
backyard in captivity it was big
they know the alligators in the ancient
days were [__] huge you know
might be the same alligator just two 300
years old
but if nearly an alligator at 100
something years old is just as healthy
and just as youthful
as a baby that they're not really aging
as we know it
so
those things might be able to get very
big
yeah because I feel like a lot of
animals especially ones that are quote
unquote primitive like that
um they tend to just like keep growing
as long as there's enough food to
sustain their size
yeah that's what that's what limits it
as far as We Know
they kind of get limited by what
whatever you know like if it's in
captivity what kind of aquarium it's in
or whatever that'll limit it and also
how much you've been feeding it
if it's
not in captivity and it's got [__]
massive amounts of [__] protein
on a regular basis it might live [__]
hundreds of years old hundreds of years
and get Giant
yeah maybe like that [__] movie that
we reviewed long ago and none of that
giant win none of that would be
happening in modern era
because
in the era when you had dinosaurs and
giant creatures there was lots of them
and uh the Earth could sustain large
amounts of these creatures it was hotter
it had a lot of CO2 an insect could get
[__] huge
you know
dragonflies with seven foot wingspans
uh
[__] foot long cockroaches which
means that it's a high CO2
greenhouse effect going on
real hot
lots of trees
and lots of CO2 and a [__] ton of oxygen
because they're looking at some of these
insects giant insects and even some of
these giant
dinosaurs and they were saying like well
that really how does that get enough
oxygen well the the [__] the
atmosphere was thicker then it had a lot
more oxygen rich you had all those
plants you know the whole thing was just
[__] Big Greenhouse big tropical
forest hot
so
you had a lot of oxygen it didn't you
could easily get a breath
so if you look at us now we're kind of
like
in the end stages of a [__]
we're a habitable planet but we used to
be a super habitable planet you know
that's that's what all the [__]
great minds on the subject say
at one time the Earth was super
habitable a creature could grow to
[__] giant proportions and still get
enough to eat
proof's there
look how big those [__] were and
there were lots of them
there's no telling what the ocean was
like I imagine it was just [__] stuff
with all kinds of [__]
huge [__]
John Smith says for nightmare fuel check
out the goblin shark yeah yeah that's
the one with like the big [__] weird
nose effect like
why did that evolve I'm sure there was a
reason but
it's not real attractive I'm sure
they're attractive to other goblin
sharks you know what I mean but and
that's all that matters really
also says at aquariums I always felt
sorry for the other fishing with the
sharks right I always kind of thought
like when I went to SeaWorld when I was
a kid
and the fact that they put the other
fish in with yes I know they feed the
sharks and everything like that but it's
like you know what if the shark just
wanted a midnight snack one night and
he's just swimming around he's like you
know
that little that little baby grouper
over there I'm just getting
just gonna go snack on it you know what
I mean
he just says they have nice
personalities
I feel kind of sorry for them because
like well
well the other sharks look kind of like
sleek and badass and everything like
that and then Here Comes goblin shark
he's just like you know it's like the
big [__] nose and everything I'm just
like oh I wonder if the other sharks
like laugh at him like how um
shakes her head no no no the only only
cat I know says no she goes shakes her
head tries to erase it yeah if she
doesn't want to do something or if you
tell her something she doesn't want to
hear she's like yeah no don't do it I
tried to grab her and she's running away
going no no no
I'm gonna get you anyway she's like no
oh you suck daddy you're getting fatter
and fatter she's not getting fatter
getting heavier and heavier she's not
that heavy coming
she's just little you're just little
look at her little faith yeah oh my
goodness
um John Smith's talking about HP love
Graf again uh his letters are
fascinating in his letters to Robert E
Howard he's racist as [__] to Robert
block he's the nicest guy ever I wonder
why
that's really interesting
Robert E Howard if he didn't know is the
guy with Conan yeah and uh Robert black
wrote Psycho among other things so um
yeah I wonder why he's like playing to
his audience I guess
I don't know that much about Robert E
Howard as a person you know what I mean
I've read some of his other stuff like
other than the Conan stuff because he
wrote like a lot of stories for weird
tales and stuff and a lot of them are on
I don't know if they're in the public
domain but a lot of them you can kind of
read online he wrote Cole the Conqueror
too yeah yeah who was kind of more like
Conan from the movie
than Conan was for the books
I haven't read any of that stuff
I probably should yeah you probably
should you might you might be into it I
don't know
I like some of his stories I'm really
into
um somebody has been digitizing like on
uh
Wikipedia Commons
um a lot of the old weird Tales from the
20s and 30s so you can read a lot of
those stories now for free like they're
on Wikipedia or it's not it's Wikipedia
Wikimedia Commons so you go on there and
you can read all this stuff and there's
a lot of Robert E Howard stuff on there
Howard committed suicide pretty young
found his mom dead if I remember
correctly and he couldn't make it he
would think he was still in his 20s
wouldn't he oh I don't know I don't
think he lived very long
I don't know like I said I don't know
that much about him as a person he wrote
a [__] tone though I feel like
he was just a pretty big Texan guy kind
of always reminded me of kind of looked
like uh Al Capone a little bit
something about the way he looked yeah
wore suits and [__]
I don't know I'm really I really liked
all those um a lot of those writers that
wrote for weird tales and
a lot of those writers that run in like
the 30s and 40s and 50s
I grew up reading a lot of those
writers like Robert block and stuff so I
still have like a kind of an affinity
for them and you know because and I grew
up watching like Twilight Zone and Night
Gallery and
you know Thriller and outer limits and
all that kind of stuff too that had a
lot of adaptations of those stories so
look at Pookie she I can't believe she's
sitting in your lap that long usually
she jumps down no she's chilling she's
mellowed out oh look at you pokey she's
not camera scared shy anymore yeah
everybody wants to see you
oh my goodness get that chin
so cute
she's I have a feeling that she's like
mad at me because I'm not here during
the day as much
like she's a little bit
not mad mad but
she kind of got upset with me yesterday
morning because I got up early because I
had some work to do before I went to
work you know what I mean
and so I'm trying to do the [__] like
hurry up before I had to leave and then
she's like Mommy Mommy and then she
jumps up on my laptop flop
like right in the middle of it and it's
like you know I'm trying to work around
her and I can't and then I was just like
okay I really have to get this done and
she was like all right the [__] the hell
with you then it just like jumped on and
she wouldn't talk to me the rest of the
day and even when I came home she was
just like hmm yeah
sometimes she'll come run to see me but
sometimes she's just it's not having it
um yeah they're talking about Seafood
Chef here it says I'll suck the juices
out of the shells and even bring my own
Lobster bib to a restaurant no shame
[Laughter]
yeah like I said I love seafood and
whenever we get a um koi one I always
kind of like
pick and choose for all because they
usually have like a lot of fish and crab
and crawfish and all that kind of stuff
so what you guys want to talk about any
questions
yeah we had like kind of a yeah lull
there we're having a low
if not we'll shut it down how long we've
been going uh hour only an hour and a
half okay an hour only that's a pretty
good that's a pretty good amount of time
I know but usually we go a lot longer
than that especially if we're not going
anyplace
so it's not like we have to rush off
anywhere
because we're not going anywhere
everyone's like concentrating on Pokey
yeah I still can't believe she's sitting
there for that long time get down she's
like no no I don't want to get down
[Laughter]
she's mad now yeah she's like why'd you
push me no she's like usually you want
me up here
yeah Victor says remember back in the
day with the five hour shows yeah it's
like now well I guess when I was less
tired
[Laughter]
let me go off on like a lot more
tangents but
did we did we ever talk about because
remember last Friday's show before we
went to mannequin and we were talking
about
um the dress code thing they were
implementing yeah that [__] didn't
[__] work yeah did we ever mention
that no I don't think so yeah
that [__] was all hyped and I was like
well we went there and like some people
were dressed up and were happy and stuff
like that but then like almost
immediately like douchey people so I'm
like it's douchier than ever like what
are they even talking about
oh my god there was just like it wasn't
as bad as as it's been like sometimes
but it was still pretty much it's like I
thought they were letting these people
in anymore
but I had fun later on John Smith said
that is an adorable kitty she is an
adorable kitty and she's
I think a lot of it too I mean she's
cute like obviously but a lot of it's
like her personality you know
because she's like
I don't know she's really a little she's
a little character she is
Penn says time for me to start working
the streets what
what are you what are you out there
doing
Zach is talking about going to uh
seafood restaurant for his birthday and
he was freaked out by the crab looking
at him the whole time
yeah I don't really like to eat anything
that has a face still on and I'll admit
that like I love Seafood but I don't
have a problem with like eating whole
crabs that doesn't bother me but I don't
want the fish with the head still on it
do you know what I mean I kind of feel
like some places do that and I'm just
like yeah thanks I don't want it looking
at me like I said
Zach said I still can't believe I'm
crushing on a dude who was old and died
when I was 15.
it happens to the best of us are you
still are you talking about Robin Gibbs
still
he died that long ago
the BG
I can't I didn't I didn't realize he
died that long ago
what you doing
getting my [__] back getting your [__]
back yeah
yeah Zach says I am indeed that's really
funny well you know
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do you know
two
John Smith says few kitties are not
adorable
Sphynx cats can [__] right off oh no
they're cute too no they're cool I like
them we used to have um somebody this
girl that used to bring her Sphynx cat
to the to Will's Pub
and he had a little sweater on and
everything I can't remember what his
name was uh
little thing from Grandma
Gizmo Gizmo Gizmo no no stripe it was
something like that yeah but she used to
bring him like in a little it kind of
looked like a Happy Meal box or
something like that she used to bring
him in that and he had his little his
little outfit on and he you would think
because if we took Pokey to the club she
would just be like [__] this and she
would go hide under a table Yeah but um
but this cat was super social yeah get
up on the [__] table he's like hey
what's up y'all get him in the middle of
a club what the hell's going on here hi
everybody look in your drink
she got there yeah
never never seen anything like it
like it transfer said Sphinx cats always
look like walking testicles to me they
can't help it yeah they do look like
they're made of ball sack skin
and they always look angry
you're not though they're nice
yeah nice nice
yeah they are kind of cool
yeah the striped Gremlin is named stripe
I thought I'd see we were trying to
remember what that cat's name was
I thought maybe it was like it was Gizmo
it was named after one of the things
from [__] grandmas
well Gizmo was the cute one but it must
have been Gizmo
unless unless his name was Mogwai which
is what Gizmo is no is a Mogwai no
but that wasn't it might have been good
I thought it was Gizmo
and I'm trying to remember what he had
on his little sweater
yeah he's wearing a sweater it was a
little sweater but I don't remember what
his little sweater was because that was
oh it was a Christmas sweater wouldn't
it
it might have been a Christmas sweater I
for some reason I thought it was like a
sports team but maybe it was a Christmas
I think it said Santa Claus on it
I see I always wanted to get Pookie
outfits but I don't think she would wear
them
I think she would just get mad
we were talking with her the other day
because she always makes um you know she
always jumps up and like makes biscuits
on your chest and stuff like that so I
wanted like a little I wanted her a
little have her a little chef coat or a
little chef hat and a little chef hat
but I don't think she would wear it we
tried to um one of you guys made a tiny
little Santa hat
actually made it for uh for Dennis back
there
for Dennis and um I tried to put it on
Pokey one year for Christmas and she was
just like not having that not having it
I saw earlier an add-on
Facebook or Instagram or something and
they have one of those little um
the little vest that you can put on the
cat that has like a leash on it so you
could take them for a walk because we
always kind of I always kind of want to
do that for Pokey but I don't think she
would do it
she doesn't seem to like to work and the
one time we tried to put
a leash or something like that on
Beijing
that was the funniest [__] ever I wish
we'd got that on video she tried to
crawl out from underneath it yeah like
we've lived the hardest she gets way
down
she's trying to like crawl over yeah she
was screaming like it was killed no
come on we'll just walk on the lead
she didn't understand leash at all so I
I gave up like well it was just putting
her through too much drama
she had no idea what it was what it was
I was doing to her why are you punishing
me yeah I think she thought we were
punishing her for something yeah
that was just it was like funny but it
was awesome like I felt really bad
Zach says why does making biscuits on
your chest sound so dirty it is dirty
man [__] I'll wake up and she's doing
this [__] on my crotch yeah you know
like this what the [__] you doing and
she'd be sitting up next to me like
she's [__] playing some [__] grand
piano or something
she's like this is like a little Mozart
yeah she's out there like composing some
[__]
might be Stevie Wonder
she goes off in a la la land
I don't know what what they're what
she's doing I've heard that I don't know
if they know if this is the case or not
but I've heard that it's because I guess
when they're kittens they smoosh on
their mom's teats or whatever like to
get milk out and I guess it's just like
a learned or like a um instinctive
Behavior so when they're raised by
humans that's just something that they
do I don't think they think about it
just trying to get Comfort yeah
because she does that a lot like she'll
come up in the middle of the night like
I guess if she's alone and then she's
like yeah
but it's super funny because like her
facial expression because she gets she
looks like she's like blissing out like
wow wow yeah it's like it's really funny
I wish I could get like video of it but
just relax quick enough it's relaxing to
her
Zach says uh that makes me think of a
video I saw of a cat that got a tissue
box stuck on its head and people drew a
sad face on it I think I saw that video
what it and I was watching I watched a
lot of videos about why cats do the
weird [__] that they do
like why they always want to get in
boxes or like crawl in these tiny little
spaces that are clearly too small for
them I guess it's because they feel
safer but
I don't know why do they always want to
get in stuff that's clearly too small
for them though like there's all kind of
videos of cats trying to crawl into like
little bitty glass bowls and yeah and
then they're like kind of all smushed up
against it like this was a terrible
mistake like you know and they can't get
out I don't know
laughs I don't know or ones that are
like stuck in between the um the uh like
the closet hangers you know the clothes
hangers they get up there like that
well that's why I don't let Pookie in
the closet anymore because she got in
there one time and almost strangled
herself on one of my bras
she like what a way to go well yeah well
I mean she jumped through the thing
unless she couldn't get out you know
what I mean so she's not allowed to go
in the closet anymore even though she
wants to go in there all the time she'll
stand there and yell but we got a pretty
big crowd in here for so late then
almost 30 people it's not that late it's
only nine o'clock yeah just keep pouring
in guys go go ahead and ask us any kind
of questions you want to if I could help
us direct this uh this conversation and
you know uh because we can't talk about
cats forever well I don't know why not
yeah I guess what people could talk
about
don't be that way yeah
well like I said it's what else has been
going on like we talked about the
mannequins thing we talked about the
nipple piercing yeah top of the nipple
piercing we talked about that on Monday
those are all healed up no problems
not so far not so no it already happened
by now yeah you know infections nothing
well like I said I got like the cream
stuff so yeah keeping that on there who
else did you send pictures to without
telling me uh no that was it okay
that was it he's telling me
[Laughter]
I had to run it by a [__] uh
a piercer guy that I know and he's like
oh yeah that's good you did a good job
[__] um
and then um
showed a couple showed a couple friends
of the shows but it's not like
picture your [__] blues hiked up
around your smiley face
it's not a good you know not like the
kind of picture I would want to share it
was medical it was a clinical clinical
we still got to do a photo shoot
yeah I know we gotta do photo shoot you
just got to get more well we're not
gonna go out this weekend well maybe we
go out tomorrow but we got we got
tomorrow
um probably cut some more tree
cut some more tree cut some more tree
yeah
that's really nice being able to drive
into the driveway without the trees
scraping all over my car like every time
I come in I got a whole [__] tree
trimmed
yeah you took a lot off of that yep
Zach says or how dogs are just chilling
out and sleeping but they're in these
hideously contorted positions where they
look all mangled but they're just fine
cats do that too they sleep not so much
Pookie but I've seen like other cats
sleep in like super weird positions oh I
got paid I gotta paint some rooms too
yeah we finally bought paint I got for
the bedroom yeah it's like a dark blue
it's a real cool kind of dark blue
yeah you know what I'm gonna paint
though should I paint the bedroom
yeah all right because we're in there
mostly I mean I feel like we could paint
it and then like I want to hang some we
don't have anything like on the walls or
anything no no like look how [__]
tricked out this [__] is yeah I know it
is just this is the bedroom this is the
most tricked out [__] room in the
house well yeah this because it's
supposed to have my empty because this
is my space and I like all this stuff so
the bedroom is like there's literally
the only thing in there is the bed
two bedside tables with lamps on them
and the TV yeah and like a little shelf
that has like DVDs and [__] on it and
cat treats it'll be real dark in there
but I have all this lighting light the
only decoration we have is like we have
um you know we we have a bunch of those
like light projector things you know
like we have in here like the color like
this light yeah but the one we have in
the bedroom is like it looks like um
like galaxies and [__] yeah Bliss light
2.0 it's good if you guys ever I think
it's about 40 bucks it's got it's pretty
it's got an app you can talk to it on
your phone you can get to the shade and
it's like a big swirling Galaxy with
[__] nebulas in it and [__]
I got Bliss like
1.0 too it's not quite as good it's just
kind of static it moves a little bit but
2.0 is the best one yeah it's kind of
it's like red green and blue like it
looks like like galaxies are like
nebulas like moving and then like blue
stars like yeah so you can change the
color and then you can get to stop
moving and it's got a bunch of stuff you
can do with it
you can put it on a timer so it's always
like before I go to sleep I always tell
time to like turn off this guy
but there's yeah it's like we've lived
in this house for
a year or so a little over a year well I
guess in September it'll be two years
Okay and like we have literally done
nothing with that bedroom there's we
haven't painted it we can afford to
there's curtains like we hung curtains
and blinds at least and there's like but
there's no art on the walls there's no
we didn't paint no nothing well we had
all the other [__] we had to do yeah had
to get a lawnmower that was [__] five
grand I think
or through efo no three grand yeah I
thought it was like 3600 yeah
but still four grand
that had to put what was it fifteen
thousand dollars with a roof on the or
ten thousand yeah because that's
something going on now now they won't
give you insurance unless you replace
your roof every [__] 10 years now
yeah that's right and then we got hit
with an extra like 200 a month because
they they said our roof is out of date
it's back in date so yeah we got it done
we're gonna get that back
it's just the same problems there but
you know everybody else has I guess and
the thing about it is that the house we
moved into like this house is a lot
bigger than our old house so it's like
we don't have
you know we didn't have a huge amount of
furniture at the other house and we have
like now it looks even less friends
over the next couple years we'll have
furniture like that living room Blake we
have a living room kind of like upstairs
like this big open area and there's like
nothing in there there's like or mini
fridges in there and our toaster oven
yeah and there's like a couple chairs
that Pookie tears out
I'm gonna try to um
I'm gonna go to Lowe's and maybe get
some wood and I'll build us the the bar
yeah
and get a sink maybe I'll be able to
find a used sink
tap it in and put a sink on the other
side of there so we have a bar sink in
the [__] yeah in the lounge
you know what I mean it would be nice to
have running water there that would be
nice yeah yeah we've got ice like I said
I kind of want to microwave in there too
one of these days it's easy yeah I mean
the toaster oven is good because you can
use that for pretty much everything but
microwaves are cheap but microwaves
aren't expensive you could just get a
little bitty but if I have microwaves at
the dollar store probably
yeah I think I think they do actually
yeah it's probably 30 bucks well I was
gonna the one before we got that toaster
oven before you got me that for
Christmas they I was gonna get a toaster
from over there they didn't have well
when I was there they didn't have a
toaster oven they just had like a
regular toaster I was like no I kind of
want to toaster oven so you could make I
got the pretty red toaster oven yeah we
got the pretty red and it matches red
nicer ice maker yeah
now all we need is a [__] red
refrigerator it's black though
yeah yeah I think they make red mini
fridges I think they make actually I
guess like red appliances are pretty
popular because they make like a lot of
red ones
air fryer
what I'll do is I can paint one of the
walls when they're blue like an accent
wall
and see if we like it you know what I'm
talking about yeah if we like I'll
continue I'll just paint the whole well
that's that my old house that I had in
Daytona yeah that's about the same color
as my bedroom was in my old house and I
really liked it I think you're the one
you got is like slightly darker like
maybe more towards Navy whereas mine was
a little bit more saturated but it's
very very similar and I really liked it
I thought it was like really relaxing I
like
I like dark colors I don't really like
um or I like dark colors or like
saturated colors I don't like any of
this [__] oh beige or like lavender
I don't like this place I'm like have a
color you're right yeah okay it's just
like if I'm gonna put color on the wall
and put some [__] color on Jack I got
an air fryer I got one of the best ones
downstairs
it's an oven toaster oven and air fryer
and Grill
got that [__] you've been making from
Sam's you've been making pizzas I can
make pizza in it and the pieces it's
really good and it's better it's good
because like in the summer you don't
have to like heat the oven up yeah it's
a lot more energy efficient it is yeah
I'll just use it on the cast iron grill
that comes out you can just oil it and
put the dough directly on the Square
cast iron grill
and put it on grill slash air fryer
maximum up on like 450 degrees
and for about 15 16 minutes and it comes
out [__] great
not as good as on Stone but but I mean
it's it's still I mean it's not a huge
difference yeah you're not using you're
not worried about a peel or anything
it's not it's just kind of like pizza
you'd get at a regular Pizzeria yeah you
know
another thing you can do is you can drop
it in one of the airfryer baskets
turn it all the way up on airfry oh no
it turned up on Pizza setting
and uh that comes out great real good
it's just that
you got to be careful with the dough the
dough has got to be real kind of tough
if not it [__] it it
drips through
the wire screen of the air fryer
um baskets
so if your dose maybe like a day too old
it would normally work on Stone but it
won't work in that [__] basket
because when it Cooks you can't get the
pizza out of the basket because the
[__] dough is kind of dripped in
between all the little holes so you can
reach into there and [__] scrape it
and knock all that [__] loose and that's
a pain in the ass and then you might be
able to get that pizza out of the basket
so you just got to be real careful what
kind of dough you're going to use
I feel like that's gotta be fresh that
air fryer though has really been a good
yeah you make a lot of stuff you don't
have to use the main oven
yeah we don't use the oven I mean we use
the other turkey to make the turkey yeah
but
then we had Thanksgiving uh for Easter
got four more turkeys
did we eat all of the other Turkey
already
we've eaten three turkeys I think three
or four turkeys like yeah I think I had
eight to me four times I thought we had
nine I thought okay I think I'd like to
start with I think I got four turkeys I
might have five
I think it's four
turkey
yeah
John Smith said since getting an air
fryer I feel like it's a cult
um I feel like the air fryer thing I
don't feel like it's quite as much of a
cult as the instant pot thing but I got
one of those two because I feel like
instant pot that was definitely like a
cult every [__] was talking about this
that's good but they're I mean they're
handy though makes good carnitas it
makes good Indian food yeah it's good
yeah and a lot of people like them you
know like for rice and stuff and like
you said they're really good for if
you're gonna make a meal and you don't
really feel like you know you just set
it before you leave for work in the
morning and then it's like ready when
you get home you gotta go to House of
spices God we haven't been a house of
spices in a long time yeah I want to get
some of that sham butter chicken mix and
I want to get some um garam masala we
can we also I guess I could run down
there on a motorcycle yeah
can we also get some paneer and make
some kind of paneer dish we haven't had
that in a really long time yeah I'll buy
some paneer
you can make paneer in that instant I
know we always say that but we never do
though yeah yeah and it's much easier to
just go to House of spices and get a big
[__] block of this [__] yeah it's
made just with milk and you can I can
use that powdered milk for to do it
though it's milk and vinegar
yeah or milk and lemon juice milk and
lemon juice that's one of those things
you just gotta cook it in the bottom of
that down fryer you make I think they
got a yogurt setting and then they got
the damn cheese setting because man you
haven't made sock paneer in a long time
and I love soccer you see I'm growing
that I'm growing all those beets out
there
beets and sweet potatoes and the greens
that come off of sweet potatoes are
better than any spinach I've used them
for on pizza I've used them for [__]
Indian food substituted [__] SOG for
sweet potato leaves
and uh what I gave you all the Taco so
it Lettuce on a Taco yeah that was
actually beet greens really and I got a
lot of beet greens and I tried them and
they're great on [__] salads for a
cold salad it's kind of like romaine
lettuce Okay so
we should get a decent yield of those
and as I was like okay we're gonna
I'm gonna put some of these aside and
let Jenny get a salad
yeah that's a good idea sound good yeah
maybe we'll have like chicken with it or
something like chicken like chicken
salad like like what do you call it
like a like a caesar salad no not a
Caesar salad what do you call it chef
salad chef salad yeah that's what it is
which is like chicken and ham or
something you know and
if I can lettuce and croutons yeah what
the hell is all in a chef salad aren't
there boiling it's kind of hard-boiled
eggs yes sliced turkey turkey ham ham uh
chicken tons cheese
lettuce and some kind of dressing
yeah I can't remember what kind of
dressing it has what kind of dressing do
this show it could be anything you want
I got a salad from Publix other day
because you know like Tuesday night when
you go to bike night I usually go down
to Publix Deli or the Chinese place and
get food and I was at Publix and they
had a really good looking salad it
wasn't a chef salad though it was
it just had some kind of like
vinaigrette on it and then it had
um like just you know your regular
greens it had slices of green apple
it had cranberries
um kind of candied almonds
and chicken like kind of Chunk like cold
chunks of
like fried chicken yeah like a little
bit like uh chicken nugget type things
and what else was in there
like there was did I say cranberries
there's cranberries in there too
yeah and there was something else but I
can't remember what it was but man that
[__] was delicious you know what else is
good
the leaves that come off of broccoli
yeah you could just dice them up and
cook them
boil them
and then once they're soft including
like all the stalks the stock [__] you
wouldn't eat
you just use your immersion blender and
puree it all right you're gonna make
like a a broccoli soup out of it cook it
down please yeah it's good
I wish I wish it was winter time so we
could make soup again yeah
[__] grilled cheese sandwich man we
never did that this last winter I kept
saying it's like man I really wanted
that I'll do it again I have tomatoes
coming
yeah
I mean we could do it in the summertime
we could just pretend but it's always
better in the winter when it's called
well
when it's cold-ish outside it's Florida
it doesn't really get that cold down
here sadly
but you know what's weird is that it's
April right but a couple mornings ago
I went out to go to work and it was you
know like 6 30 in the morning or
something like that it was 50 degrees
outside yeah I was like what the [__]
state am I in yeah that never happens in
April yeah not Florida every now and
then like I remember a couple years
where we had a really cold night like in
March but that's very unusual and we've
never like usually by the time April
rolls around it's like [__] 90
degrees already or like 85. John Smith
since he got that air fryer says he
rarely uses his oven yeah you really
only need that to cook something big now
yeah we don't use ours lunch anymore I
forgot what I call it it's an air fryer
oven Grill it's it's like it's pretty
big yeah it's pretty big it's a good one
I think I paid 150 for it at Sam's which
is that's not bad at all it's not bad at
all yeah like for
for all that it does because you can
make like all like I said it's about
yeah it's about that big one thing I
don't like about it is the Chinese don't
[__] think ahead bro every knob on it
is slick in Chrome so if you've got
moist hands from working in the kitchen
if it's wet you try to turn a knob it
just slides over it they don't bother
putting a paddle on it or [__]
knurled ends or anything then [__]
crazy you'd be like you gotta [__]
get a towel a dry towel to turn the
[__] knobs
crazy see I'd be having all kinds of
problem with that because you know how
[__] clumsy yeah they're [__]
chromed and slick as glass it doesn't
make anything they're like well it looks
good yeah you can't [__] turn the
damn knob
yeah that would be uh Victor said my
ninja air fryer is amazing yeah I feel
like a lot of people got into it like I
said that in the instant pot I feel like
the instant pot was more of a cult but
yeah the air fryer thing is too but the
thing about it is that I kind of
understand it because
it is very very handy instant pot works
though it does yeah that's what I mean
all it is
it can be a pot
where you can saute
and it's also a pressure cooker yeah and
it's got It's some settings on there but
it's an easy to use pressure cooker I'm
not quite as scared of it as a real
pressure I think that's kind of what the
thing I'm scared of pressure cooker yeah
like back in the old days yeah like my
grandma had a pressure cooker and every
time she was using that I'm like I'm
just gonna go to the other end of the
house how about that
that [__] exploded things went wrong
with with air with things went wrong
with pressure cookers over the years and
explosions happened and real explosions
you know yeah boom you know [__]
blowing walls they used to kill bombs
out of those yeah
so you know I just I kind of feel like
they're still kind of scary but I feel
like they're they figured out how to
make them like a little bit safer just
like it could probably still explode but
if you're really that sensors in there
it knows when but yes and [__] goes
wrong it shuts itself off right so I
feel like knows when there's not enough
fluid in there back in the 70s they
didn't have all those safety matches so
you were just like well if it blows up
it blows up
sucks to be you what was great about
pressure cookers is you could take dry
beans
or peas or whatever
and get a meal in minutes instead of
having to soak that [__] overnight is
slow cook stuff for [__] hours to get
[__] beans rehydrated and pressure
cooker
20 minutes you know and you can cook a
big old piece of [__] low quality
meat like a shoulder
a pork shoulder you can put that in
there and have it tender and succulent
in about 20 minutes 30 minutes 40
minutes [__] I've even seen him do that
on Master Chef like where they have like
the time limit and they're just like hey
I'm gonna make these big like big thick
pork chops or whatever I'm gonna make
them in the pressure cooker and they
come out like perfect after 30 minutes
or whatever yeah
yeah Victor said the Boston Marathon
bomb was a pressure cooker that's what I
thought
and that's yeah they always used to be
really scary because like I said my
grandma used to have like one of those
old like 60s ones well what they did is
they did that because [__] I don't maybe
I can say nothing what I don't want to
give away bomb making excuses
they didn't it was they just used it as
a casing okay because other thing that
you commonly use as a casing is ease
when you go to buy it at a hardware
store they go this motherfucker's
building a bomb
but you go down to Walmart and get a
pressure cooker people don't go there
he's probably building a bottle I mean I
would think that but that's just me
so there's a lot of pressure cookers go
out because I always like to think the
worst of somebody but the thing that you
normally would buy to make it to make a
casing you go give me this and it needs
to be a foot long and this amount of
diameter give me ends to it and [__]
[__] [__] you're making bombs
yeah because it's obvious what you're
making so you use the pressure no I'm
just because it's a metal container that
locks it has a positive lock you put
a booster and an explosive inside that
and you have it wired so you can talk to
the booster
[__] then you got a decent casing
if you've got a [__] bet in the
reason why they did that is because they
didn't have a high explosive
I had a low explosive so you're just
gonna have to be in a bomb case
if you put a high explosive in a casing
you get more out of it you get more
shroud
but high explosive doesn't need a casing
all right [__] that can just be
because it goes off it it's got a shock
wave good enough to be effective not
after very far but
but those guys were they were not using
high explosive so they had to use that
they had to use the bomb cases for that
for that what was what was that it was a
Marathon Boston Marathon yeah
yeah
Hugo says hey guys I want a t-shirt but
I only use PayPal can't do Super Chat uh
I can do I can do PayPal yeah Center the
order I'll make it just uh yeah send me
a message on somewhere on social media
and I know what size is it what size do
you need and what what what design do
you want
but I'll tell you what the what the
PayPal email is yeah
if it's real big I have to call it's
like it's an extra extra large I
probably have to charge a little bit
more
well those shirt the blank shirts
somewhere a little bit more expensive
that's what I'm saying yeah yeah they
well they usually only start charging
more after like 2XL I think yeah
John Smith says uh our grows late for me
I'll have to call it a night have a good
one y'all uh good night uh Victor said
my classmate was running the marathon
that day the Boston Marathon he had
already finished though like when that
bomb went off yeah I remember that I
remember that that was a long time ago
but yeah
um yeah yeah Zach said it's the end of
April it was in the 30s here last night
what the [__] yeah it's I mean it was
hot as balls today I'm not saying that
but the mornings have been actually like
pretty cool and pleasant and I was
shocked as hell when I walked out the
door the other day and it was 50 [__]
degrees I was like oh my god do I have
to go back and get a jacket I did not
funny thing about
bombs
is that if you go through history
they're obsolete those dudes that did
that [__] none of them got what they
wanted
they got attention but they didn't give
what they wanted
nowadays you can do the same thing with
a [__] good video a video that goes
viral it's just as effective
as a is that um
when you actually looked at what the
bomb did the bomb called attention to
the dude and what his issue was that was
it
but he still didn't get his way you can
do that with the video nowadays A lot of
it a lot of force that terrorists and
militaries used to use in the past
is ineffective now kind of like obsolete
in a certain way like the tank
the battle the main battle tank
those are only good for
fighting other tanks and other
conventional armies usually it's some
kind of Border Skirmish you're trying to
get inside somebody's country
but if you're in something like civil
Strife or civil unrest or
a country divided into pieces or
breaking apart tanks are useless
I mean what are you gonna do with it
bomb people's houses blow up people's
houses you know you don't need it you're
already inside the territory that you
want so you don't need a
the highest form of warfare is
informational Warfare it was just
basically psyops and [__] mind
control propaganda that's the highest
form of it
sure said whatever happened to David
June I remember I bought him a shirt
once yeah
um I haven't seen him in a little while
it hasn't been that long I think it's
only been like a week or two I think he
was here a couple weeks ago but
I'm still wondering whatever happened to
some of our like what happened to Sandra
from Germany yeah what happened to Tila
yeah I'm gone Taylor was in San
Francisco so she did we make that mad or
something no I don't know
she'd have been gone for about a year
yeah it's been a while yeah
so what shirt did that guy want I don't
know he didn't say it okay well like I
said just send me a message on Facebook
or Instagram or something like that and
I'll tell you what the um
with the uh yeah I can tell you if I got
it in stock too I mean we have a lot of
blank shirts here a lot of blank shirts
but because I ordered like a [__] ton of
them like a while back just in one big
bulk order well he's talking to Jenny
before the show started so I wanted to
get some new designs I want to get a
Honky Kong shirt
which for this is going to have the it's
going to say instead of Donkey Kong in
the same font
and everything is just going to say
hockey con and I might have the [__]
gorilla all right Jenny wants to put my
face on that gorilla but that gorilla is
so low res it wouldn't work so we're
just gonna do that [__] stupid
gorilla and people are gonna go wait a
minute hold on that doesn't say Donkey
Kong I wanted to do that
and um
we got to come up with another one
I mean I've been writing down ideas for
stuff but it's like I write them down a
little pieces of paper and I don't know
I want a hockey card I might want to
eventually I want a vanilla gorilla
shirt
you want an abdominal snowman maybe
we'll get an abdominal snowman these are
all about you
well they're just general
I want to wear it it's funny on the show
I should be a gag man but we go
we got to come up with some I really
love this design that you made we got to
come up with some more of this kind of
stuff yeah I think it'd be awesome
well one of the when I have time like I
said one of these days I don't have a
lot of time anymore but you know yeah
because for something like that
I told you whenever I'm designing sure I
mean you know I'm not saying I don't
overthink [__] when I'm designing [__]
for other people because I totally do
but when I'm designing stuff for my own
self or for the show or something like
that it takes me like three times longer
because for whatever reason I'm always
like super I'm way more picky like with
our own stuff yeah Victor was thinking
the same thing I was thinking he said
Tina was cool as [__] but she's probably
a catfish I was thinking I mean she was
here a lot like a long time there that
that's like a if you're a catfish that's
like a long game yeah yeah it might have
been a catfish account
yeah Tammy said last time Tila was here
was close to Mother's Day last year yeah
yeah so it was like almost a year ago
because holy [__] Mother's Day is coming
up again
because it's almost may she was trying
to get out of San Francisco San
Francisco falling apart
Sandra got eaten by wildebeest please
leave a message she was eating all that
damn peanut butter and she blew up maybe
that's what it was yeah she got mad
because I was talking about Germany and
[__] mustache man then she never came
back that's what I think
mad at me they came back
[__] um
uh our friend from the club [__] [__]
manager
Shawna Shawna yeah you guys are asking
about Shawna
Shawna made up with me
I don't know if I totally it may be true
she said that I've Got Drugs says yeah
I'm gonna get some of that one day and
she got mad at me at the club which that
sounded kind of like something
yeah but I was [__] around but she
got mad about that so she came up and
she's doing are we just gonna ignore
each other and be mad it says I ain't
ignoring you the [__] this and it's
you the one that's been on it so we made
up she's all right
a little while
she's gonna be okay though Victor said I
got mad at you but never left
[Laughter]
that's because my gay fans are solid man
they're waiting for me to open that only
fans account bro well you did open it
yeah have Jenny [__] filming my
[__] solo scenes and [__]
she can reach over and give me a hand
he's really yeah it'll just be my hand
in the video
Jenny's hand and [__]
I better get a manicure if my hands are
there yeah a camera had me dressed up as
[__]
he'd be the hand could be the thing from
[__] oh yeah and you had he had me
dressed up like [__] Lurch no like
like [__] Wednesday Adams oh that's
even better yeah me dressing like
Wednesday Adams and the [__] you have
little braids the things the thing is
[__] jerking me and [__] that's a
good idea I think you should do that and
then I grabbed the camera turn it back
and [__] blow your cover it's her
[Laughter]
kinky as [__] [__] okay I like I like
that idea yeah Calhoun's here you
probably wouldn't do it my boy Calhoun
listens to [__]
he's not here right now but he listens
to record and he I was talking to him
about it and I was even coming up with
ideas and she said oh yeah he goes like
I'd subscribe to that I'm subscribe
today
okay so we were talking about this the
other day because we were talking about
um I guess we were started talking about
the only this was like last weekend I
guess if we were talking about like the
only fans thing we were kind of like
making jokes about what we put on there
and everything
um but then we were talking about or you
were telling me about that video you're
watching about that woman that was like
an escort or she had been a performer
and so she was talking about that Ayla
right yeah yeah yeah that's what you
were telling me about that yeah and I
was like um you know more power to him
like women that can do like be escorts
and uh you know do porn and stuff like
that she's an Asperger psycho though
well right well that's what I mean and I
was just kind of like here's the thing
like I would have a lot of difficulty
being like doing escort thing it's
because you have to like pretend to be
nice to people and I'm not good at doing
that however
um what we were talking I said you know
what though I said if I could be one of
those [__] like a dominatrix
type thing where like dudes would come
and I didn't have to like have sex with
them or anything but I could just like
[__] step on their balls and like kick
them and like make them eat out of a dog
bowl and stuff I could totally do that
yeah well that would actually be really
fun no there there are there are girls
that [__] specialize on that that's
what I mean see I could do that like
because I could just be mean to people
and I could just be the biggest [__]
I could be had me there get paid for it
you'd have to have me there as security
and I could add to the [__] pain and
discomfort right laughing at the dude
see and I was and I was like maybe we
should do that yeah yeah
that's a lot of fun I'll go back on
Trend and I'll be extremely cruel
because I said like I said I do because
the girl that you were talking about
yeah it's like even though she kind of
um but she kind of sounded like me in a
lot of ways so like kind of aspergery
but yeah um so but she was apparently
really good at playing roles and like
being nice to people that I'm really not
good at that so just like and I'm really
not good at like pretending to like
people are not like them and so but if I
could just be mean to people and like
just beat the [__] out of them and step
on their nuts and stuff and then they
would like thank me and pay me
afterwards that would actually be pretty
cool I should do that she wasn't so much
playing roles she didn't do what she was
is that she was um
she's gen she's kind of disconnected
from it right and compartmentalize
everything
and she says some crazy [__]
she realized that when she became an
escort she's real pretty she's gonna
live Taylor her name is aiella it's
a-e-l-l-a you guys can look at her she's
been on [__] a bunch of talk shows
and [__]
and she left a Christian cult and she
said because what she learned the
behaviors that she learned in a
Christian cult actually helped her be
that makes total sense she started off
as a cam girl
and then uh got burned out on it
and tried escorting she liked escorting
a lot better because it was personal
like one-on-one
relationship kind of contact with these
people
couldn't really have real relationships
with boyfriends per se she's kind of
pansexual in a way
um what they call it
Polly she's uh polyamory
so her boyfriend's just kind of came and
went
and she used escorting as kind of like a
cake that she couldn't really control
who the guy was as long as he he passed
her background checks and was paying and
she's expensive she was like twenty six
hundred dollars an hour for the first
hour and twelve hundred dollars an hour
after that man that's been pretty fun
that's what she was making
and she started off cheap but she said
that she had to work more and the dudes
were shittier so she just started
raising the price and the guys became
more enough because that's the thing if
you if you charge like not that much
money then people perceive you as like
yeah yeah so she got rid of all the
[__] little guys and all ends up with
these dudes who are 65.
business owners wife haven't [__] him
in 10 years and they're not really
players at all they're you know [__]
Magoo you know basically she's dealing
with Magoo and she Twisted her mind
around to where she could [__] get
off on how ugly and old the [__]
was that and how wrong it was like you
know how right the physical difference
it became like a kink to her
but she um
because the the guys that paid more
money tended to be nicer and more uh
harmless
and she said that you get those because
when the price goes up
the guys who are more bashful and more
successful see well she's not desperate
she must be a good person right that's
what it is yeah that makes sense so they
start preferring her
and she goes to [__] on tour in
Europe makes a million dollars in a
month and then comes back out because
she's booked all these dudes
yeah okay
so she's not poor she's very rich she's
probably one of the richest hookers in
existence and she's not even 30 yet
she is very intelligent but she's crazy
too if you ask me she's kind of crazy we
all crazy yeah she's crazy
um
but she wasn't playing roles what it was
is that
she was very naturalistic in whatever
the dude
was due and she kind of had empathy for
that guy in a certain in a certain way
but then as soon as it's the experience
is over it's like in a compartment and
she would write down everything about
that client what they did yeah and who
orgasm or didn't orgasm so she keeps a
file on all these dudes well that's a
good idea
then you know like all of their all of
their [__] like yeah
they're whales basically they spend
[__] 10 grand on her
you know basically well and you said
sometimes they'd pay for her to like
hang out with them for like a week you
have like a week yeah like I said to me
that sounds like exhausting yeah she
she says all of her clients are
unattractive but she does like them
yeah if she doesn't like him she doesn't
do she doesn't go back to him right
because she's not desperate she can pick
and she can pick and choose yeah
I mean the ones with money that are like
nice to her
but like I said I kind of feel like
I don't know I just it takes a different
kind of person than me to do that kind
of stuff because I'm just wouldn't be
good especially one that was you know
um like a week long I said because it's
like it's bad enough that I don't have
like a lot of patience like I said and
if like a person annoys me I'm not just
not gonna like put up with it for very
long so
I just I don't know I I couldn't pretend
to be
to like that person when you're like an
hour much less a week
she's got a she's got a Twitter and she
and her and friends are hers who are
also [__] escorts will post [__]
memes
kind of poking fun at their clients when
you see the type of client that it is
you're like yeah that is kind of [__]
pit
a younger woman has to pretend to be
interested in these dudes like they're
interesting they're not they're boring
boring dude well and I wonder if deep
down like the dudes have to know that
right yeah they know it they know
they know but well it's fantasy right
it's fantasy
sex drive for a guy is always the same
pretty much throughout his whole life it
just kind of slows down after 50 but
it's still about the same uh
for a guy it's the sex drive is like
hunger really more than anything else
it's just a
it's just a biological drive it's
hormonally based for women sex isn't
really like that's more like a mood you
know
and it's super complicated it's yeah
it's a lot more complicated it's
cyclical and as women age it changes a
lot
so they're not quite as driven
after you know 50 or so
the man keeps on going
so it's just that his you said his
refractatory period and and his he kind
of his regeneration period isn't quite
as
short as it was it was younger but it's
still there
just like you you're always going to be
hungry for food when you get hungry you
know it's just the same thing
yeah
well like I said it's you know
we're a lot but she's an interesting
she's interesting person
she's crazy though
but she's smart enough to know what she
gave up for all this
you know she says you know like I know
the deal she's like cooking you know I'm
gonna be Polly basically for the rest of
my life
I will probably die alone as an old lady
just I'll probably never get married
because the guys that I would marry
would not marry me right that's what she
said she says but I don't really she
sees like but I'm not really big into
marriage I think marriage is not really
necessary unless you're real old and you
need a partner basically so she's a so
there's some logic to what she said but
it's a very aspergy asperger-ish you
know what I mean she's not well she's
really emotional she's almost like a
male thinking well she's looking at
things just from a like a pragmatic
standpoint like I said I kind of look at
things like that as well
kind of a male strategy like you feel
emotions and stuff but they don't quite
affect you the same way right it's just
kind of like you everything is just sort
of like pragmatic concerns yeah you know
what I mean you have to like weigh all
these options well if I do this or if I
do that you know what I mean so it's so
it's that kind of thing and you know the
way that yeah I haven't seen her but the
way that you talked about her she does
sound like she has her [__] I thought I
showed it to her showed her to you no
you were we were just talking about it
we were just talking about it in the car
remember like on the way back from uh
okay I thought I should from kaiwan or
whatever
because I got because I got like
momentarily like all excited I was like
oh man maybe we should maybe we should
start a business where I step on dude's
balls and stuff
it's better than having like a
nine-to-five job right well like I said
if they if they literally if they oh
yeah yeah okay if they legit like paid
me to like be mean to them yeah I could
totally do that answer I don't want to
[__] them or nothing though yeah you
couldn't escort
well I wouldn't want to do that anyway I
feel like I said that's not my thing but
like I said if dudes like just want me
like to pay me like to kick him in the
nuts I can do that but we have a
background the FED a scene you know I've
got the fetish people that shit's just
fantasy it's not real sex right that's
what I'm saying so I could do that like
I could just yeah I could just like I
said put a leash on a dude make him eat
like you know clean this little dog's
tongue or something like that tell him
what a [__] Stampy is he ain't
packing nothing he's hung like a [__]
chipmunk dude man no wonder
[Laughter]
see I could do that well because
remember
remember when I think we were talking
about this the other day where we came
across that that whole sub-genre of porn
that was just like um you know like just
women in high heels like stepping on
dudes nuts yeah that was [__] very
difficult for me to [__] and like Tom
couldn't watch it and I just I thought
it was hilarious I just like laughed and
I was like let's watch another one okay
look dude was laying on his back so
funny he had his jump
going through a hole in a board yeah
two two by two foot
in this hot chick with these [__]
just Wicked looking [__] stiletto
heels and she's just [__] stepping on
his nut on his testicle yeah
man she was getting in there too [__]
stepping on him and [__] and I was like
damn look at that I was like are they
gonna burst I'm like watching
another one that was making me [__]
crawl up the [__] wall she had this
German porn star [__] lover she's
[__] skinny [__] giant [__]
implants these huge [__] Rings
[__] she's pierced [__] pierced labia
these [__] huge rigs oh I know it
when you figure out is the [__] top
of a [__]
soda canned
she takes this [__] metal sounding
rod and goes down her boyfriend's
[__] urethra yeah I remember that I
just [__] god
at the top of my [__] head and she's
saying German [__] to him I don't know
what the [__]
she's fine as hell torturing this dude
he's just I I don't even know what that
feels like I don't know what that I
don't want to know what that feels like
I just imagine that that [__] must hurt
I imagine that [__] must [__] hurt it
yeah I mean sounding I don't I don't
think that's all that widespread when I
sold sex toys online like I sold a
couple of those kids but not a lot oh
man it's not a lot
I was worn out by that Jenny said lying
next to me laughing her ass
oh I might be a little bit sadistic I'm
not actually sure
I enjoy watching dudes get punished what
you know what I mean yeah I don't know
why it's very funny we got all the
[__] Audio Visual and graphic design
technology will set you up as a
dominatrix that could be your [__]
security we go [__] torture these
[__] that's what I said yeah you
ready don't worry we're gonna do it easy
okay put that [__] up on Tris we want
well we want some we want some people
they're gonna pay now because I don't
have to I don't want to have to work all
the time I just want to like you know oh
no we'll give it like a [__] two-hour
session that's just gonna be [__] a
grand at least I mean you know I want to
just do like a couple sessions and like
be able to pay my [__] yeah like well
you can't be desperate that's what I'm
saying if you're gonna go do this [__]
[__] it's gonna be a couple Grand
he said I need to I need to just side
money yeah
I need to go to like dominatrix school
well I mean I need to learn to be we
know all the people for that yeah I know
I need to learn to be much you just
teach you to [__] be a dominatrist
you got that you got the outfits already
that's true yeah
and you already got security so
and I could help
yeah tie that [__] up beat him up
[__] drag the [__] out bring out the
[__] again
I got to Camp right here yeah [__]
yeah no problem
I could handle that okay we've been all
the [__] fetish shows
the thing is is they'd probably be our
friends
I know you well yeah we know you
yeah it's kind of a small community you
know yeah
[Laughter]
I don't know I'm just thinking that's
like a new Earth that's like a new
career you're gonna have to get you a
[__] dominatrix name
yeah I'll think of something cool
mistress
mistress yeah he can't think of anything
something to do with books
[Laughter]
because I'm such a nerd yes
that's okay I don't know I'm not ashamed
of being a nerd mistress icicle
that's probably [__] taken up I don't
like that anyway no good it's too long
okay
and I feel like people don't know how to
spell it or either you know what I mean
you have to like you have to dump
everything down because people are
idiots we gotta get you the big [__]
dominatrix hair
like from the 80s now they had the
[__] big hair yeah yeah all the
extensions and [__] yeah I'm gonna have
to because I can tease this [__] but
yeah it needs more volume
I was thinking about teasing it tonight
if we went out but yeah I always see I I
really like my hair teased like I like
the way it looks but then like and I
always go out and I'm like man my hair
looks amazing but then like the next day
I'm always like why did I do this why
because it's like then it's just all
knots
because my hair like knots up even
without me teasing it like all I have to
do is kind of go like that and it just
knots up so look at the Victor said
where is it I'd hire Jenny to be my zoom
dominatrix she would yell at me to do my
taxes
[Laughter]
baby
maybe that could be a whole side thing I
can do [__] over [__] sake yeah like
it just yells can you blow it out and go
that is so [__] pathetic that's so
[__] pathetic I jump out and she goes
this is a real man
it sounds like super fun this is like
something I could do that's something I
could do
because I could just be like well I
don't the thing about it is that I don't
I feel like like look I'm a nice person
I'm a nice person right
um well kind of
but I kind of feel like I'm like I don't
know like I'm a low-key [__] but I
don't really get to be an [__]
because I don't really like
confrontation so I don't really want to
be like an [__] to people's faces
unless I'm like drunk and then I will
but you know what I mean so I kind of
feel like doing that would be like a
good outlet for me because I would get
to just be like a complete twunt
and like not get and get paid for it and
get like rewarded so it'd be like
win-win you know what I mean you gotta
get uh gotta get over [__] try to get
over your field of body fluids because
you can be you're gonna be [__]
spitting on people
that's true probably pissing on people
too
maybe we'll drink it here you drink that
yeah that's pretty gross yeah they do
that kind of [__] yeah I know yeah but I
mean you could I mean you could have
parameters too because some people don't
really like it seriously I was reading
now I'm probably gonna make myself gag
saying this but
I was reading and maybe like I don't
know about this weekend but I might put
up another book review but I actually
ended up reading two novellas because I
didn't know there were novellas when I
first started reading them so they were
like really short and the one that I
read yesterday like on my lunch hour
um it was one of those extreme novels
which I didn't really know I just picked
it at random and um yeah there was a
there was a scene in there with um
some vomit that I was not expecting and
I was like
that was just like that the whole lunch
hour so you know there's some gross [__]
in that in there it wasn't the worst
thing I ever read I mean I've read way
worse than that but it was still pretty
gross
Zach says there's a Finnish movie that
came out a few years ago it's about a
Dominatrix and it's basically the chick
from The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo is
one it looks awesome ooh
I might need to watch that
get some pointers was that Hugo talking
about Secrets oh yes please can shirt
yeah I wrote it down full skin shirt
large okay yeah pretty sure we have lar
I always buy like a lot of I think I got
a large large we usually run out of
mediums first because I buy a lot of
mediums but Tom usually uses them all
but not all of them but a lot of them
yeah so I'm usually short on mediums but
we should have I think we have some
larges though
so we could print that out uh
yeah yeah
but uh yeah so what time is it oh holy
[__] it's almost 10 o'clock yeah I think
it's called dogs don't wear pants Oh
that's on um shutter or it was I don't
know if it's still on there but I
remember saying I didn't watch it but I
remember seeing it on there a while back
so I might have to watch that now like
the trailer did look kind of cool when I
watched it a long time ago I didn't
realize it was about a Dominatrix and
I'm really gonna have to watch it
they make some weird movies over there
in Europe you know
um
you ready to yeah yeah wrap it up here
yeah you seem like you're spacing out a
little bit about the alcohol is getting
me yeah
I was just thinking about getting
another one though
there's more
oh I know there's more there's always
there's always more for you little girl
[Laughter]
oh it's getting weird
yeah he's gonna hook you right up
all right
I can't believe it's almost 10 o'clock
holy crap yeah Victor said if y'all
watch piggy yet that was good no I
haven't watched that yet
Zach says I love Finnish people they're
like European Hillbillies and they're
hilarious
I've heard a lot of stories about the
fans
have you really yeah some of the uh
programs I listened to if I could talk
about Finland a lot one of the guys his
name was Dr Professor or something or
other [__] afraid his name but he's
he lives in Finland he's a British guy
living in Finland and he always makes
comments about how
how he can go to Finland and he'd be the
life of the party because Finns are so
kind of reserved and they're kind of and
they kind of emulate everything from the
outside world uh like they [__]
really like emulate PC type stuff even
though it's like an all-white country
and they have no idea what the [__]
talking about they just try to be like
everybody else even though they're
nothing like everybody else you know
they're
fans and they're all finished and
they're very uniform very kind of what
do you call it homogeneous but they
don't really want to be
they well it's kind of like a white
version of the Japanese because it's
like boring yeah yeah they're boring
they're kind of like white the white
version of Japanese so it's like they're
you know they're like what I want to be
like let's listen yeah I want to be the
same as everyone else right yeah
Tammy says are you gonna make tank tops
for women we can I got them I can do
anything you want like just as long as I
have like some lead time because I just
I order blanks from I don't know if I
have any tank tops in there right now
but I have ordered them from we get our
shirts blank shirts from Jiffy shirts
and there's a couple different tanks we
can use we got some girl tanks I got guy
tanks like that one yeah like this one
and uh it depends on exactly what you
want but we got tags I mean what are you
trying to achieve I mean if you're
trying to achieve something then
you know [__] uh yeah I can make sure
that it happens that's what I'm trying
to say because Jiffy shirts that's where
I get and they have all different like
Cuts yeah so if you want like something
specific yeah as long as you give me
enough time like you let me know like
like I said you want a scoop neck you
want a v-neck you want a long sleeves
you want a hoodie you want like it's
like you know I want a half shirt just
with your titties yeah I can get like
pretty much anything you want they have
like a whole bunch of different even if
you wanted different color or something
like that like they have a million
different things to pick from so as long
as I have like lead time I can figure
out
um you know like what you want and I can
get it it just might take a little while
uh but yeah so I guess we're gonna wrap
it up right yeah because it's 10 o'clock
so uh Sunday we'll probably do a movie
review are we gonna do um King of New
York because yeah xanadas sent us king
of Newark so we're gonna watch that
probably tomorrow night uh or later
tonight or I don't know and uh we'll
talk about that on Sunday so hopefully
you guys can come by and hang out with
us then uh so what what Tammy said no no
half shirts
daddy's gonna pop out I mean you know
okay I just got a really cool
um I should have worn it actually now
that I'm thinking about it I got a
really cool it's kind of like a half
hoodie
of um Opera the Dario Argento movie it's
like long sleeve but the shoulders are
cut out and it's got like chains
you know hood and everything yeah it's
super cool and it has if you've seen
like the poster for the Dario or gentle
movie Opera which came out in 1987 it
has like the girl with the pins like
taped under her eyes like to keep her
eyes open and uh so it's got that on it
but maybe I'll wear it Sunday
or whatever so everybody can see it
because it is like really cool looking I
tried it on but uh yeah so we will see
you guys on Sunday thanks for dropping
by thanks for your super chats and all
of that and we'll see you then